hello everyone hello hello um we were snuffy and i we were
doing some tech support today and it did not go so well so
at first at first i i got everything set up like i was like
good to go i was like i got this and then i was like i got
the server already it was going to be hosted on my end
because they said you can do that and i was like are stuffy
you download all these mods just to be sure and then i was
like all right join my server and then she for some reason
it was like failed to connect and you're like oh something's
wrong failed to connect i was like oh what and then i was
like all right so how about i join you and then i tried
joining her and it was like failed to connect maybe the host
is offline or firewalls or some shit and then i was just
like this is the mods we uninstalled all the mods and was
like going on a full the mods that i wanted to do was
proximity chat by the way the proximity voice comms um like
i the thing is while all this was happening and i was like
directing snuffy on how to do this and this she had her
entire screen shared to me so while i was like explaining
stuff and i was just like okay so i'm gonna do this and i'm
gonna do that i heard i see her pull up go on chrome and i
see her pull up heated rivalry while i'm trying to plain
text support to snuffy somebody sent me a link I swear and I
was just like oh I guess I'll just click this and see how
did you know and I was like snuffy I can see your screen
what do you mean how do I know for those who don't know what
heated rivalry is it's basically gay hockey drama so it's
about two men in hockey in Canadian uh one Canadian one
Russian who are in the closet and it's like the newest big
show right now on hpo right so and they're all like in the
clouds and you're having the secret gay relationship um um
and they're hockey players and taking a lot of information
don't you everyone knows about heated rivalry i just haven't
watched it and it was like my first glimpse into heated
rivalry and then i just see them like fucking work like they
were like working out and like together and shit and then
they were working out yeah and then and at one they were
like in the locker room fully naked and everything and i'm
like stuffy what the it took paela's oldest time and then i
was like and i'm like trying to fix the server while i was
trying to rent the server by the way i accidentally bought
two servers because i was impatient um she was so distracted
i'm sure yeah yeah yeah so like obviously we couldn't do
like our own private server so i tried renting a server and
because we couldn't connect to each other like i had
everything i tried to prep everything beforehand but i just
forgot one thing and it was just stuffy just couldn't
connect to my server and i couldn't connect to her server
like that was just the one thing i just did not anticipate
happening um oh also i did turn down stuffy a little bit so
sound again let me know if it's better um testing testing am
i good don't you chat it's good for me too by the way you
guys yeah let me know if stuffy's okay um and then like i i
was at first i it on PayPal and then it was taking a while.
So like I was like, okay, let me just grab my credit card.
And then by the time I grabbed my credit card, put the
information down, the PayPal payment went through.
The moment I got everything, because I refreshed, I was
like, let me double check to make sure the PayPal payment
went through.
Because I waited like 10 minutes.
And then it went through the moment I typed in my credit
card information.
So now I have two hightail servers now.
I guess one of them i'll gift it to you guys you can go
fucking wild if you want um and then what else oh yeah and
then while i was like trying to get vox proximity mod to
work because all the other mods work we just had three mods
by the way i'll show you it's not that big of a thing it was
just like dumb mods um but the one mod that was not working
was the voice proximity mod and i was like trying to figure
out was like resetting my server and then i hear some very
suspicious noises on my second monitor.
Because obviously I wasn't tuned in to Heater Ravory while
trying to do tech support.
Yeah, that's why you kept messing up server setup.
Totally not because you were distracted.
And then, like, I heard some very suspicious noises.
I tad back into Snuffy's screen share.
And then I saw the two gay hockey players in a hotel room in
bed.
And I was like, oh!
Oh, they're finally i was like before that i was like when
the are they gonna man like i was just like bro they're just
we're all it's just all yapping when the are they gonna bang
and then at that point they were they were about to bang and
snuffy by the way was silent throughout all of this by the
way she was so locked in you were oh yeah yeah it's your
like morning coffee yeah what were you to say it was like
your fucking morning coffee yeah she was so locked in yeah
so um so anyway um they were getting at it while i'm like
freaking freaking out about voice proximity in my headphones
i just hear here two gay men getting the time of their lives
as my i guess my background just a little curious yeah and
then yeah and then he was like let me show you how it's done
i was like oh my god
i was like eating my popcorn during all of this i was just
like no way i can't believe he's actually gonna do this
episode i was like oh my god she's like oh i didn't even
check what the show was rated i just kept that up that was
that was not i know for certain that was not the first
episode i know for a fact that that had been the first
there's no way you just that was not the first episode stuff
either way it escalated i have no i have no way of verifying
because i've never seen another episode there's no way while
i was doing tech support you were doing your first watch of
heated rivalry in the background i didn't know i was gonna
be like a whole thing i was just like oh let me see what
this is all about wait and then you know it seemed like you
were so into it so apparently it is they fuck on the first
episode yeah okay yeah so yeah they didn't fuck on the first
episode it wasn't fucking it was like he was teaching him
something else he was yeah he was teaching he was teaching
him something else but it was not
you say what was it there was a a particular method the
grapefruit method yes so yeah he did it first to his senpai
and he like scoffed at him and he was just like hey not bad
for your first time and then he's like now let me let me
help let me show you how it's done they were so much louder
when he did it there was like no audio and the first guy did
it and then it got real like sloppy as my white noise while
i was trying to figure out how the fuck to get voice
proximity but it's okay it sounded like she was practically
pacing her room she's like i don't know if this is gonna
work i don't know why this isn't how do i enable pvp and i'm
just like this is freaking great it's like it's my breakfast
i was like okay i'm gonna try and do this now And then in my
background was just two closeted hockey players just having
the time of their lives, I guess.
Hell yeah.
Anyway, welcome to Hytale.
Sorry that we were there.
I really did want to get voice proximity to the work because
I thought it would be like pretty funny.
Also, I don't know if we have PvP because I can't figure
this out at all.
It was like, look at configuration.
um there's the pvp enabled uh text on there and i looked at
it and i do not see no pvp text on there so um i guess we'll
see how i'll hit you and see if you take damage that's the
best i can do if i hit you first all right well let's see
what we okay we have to fight or flight instinct yeah i
didn't know there was pay to win cosmetics dude that's crazy
oh yeah i bought the 60 plus dollars thing yeah i bought it
yeah i just knew this game was gonna be that good yeah i
yeah i just knew it damn i had that feeling um anyway let's
let's let me customize i think i made my gig already bro did
you see the guy that gave me on default
i look like i look like link bro they just gave me like just
like hipster bro that's my first fucking character I was
like what the oh this looks like you were gonna release a
banger song in 2010 yeah really this looks like my hair the
most I don't know I'll get this yeah this looks like my
summer hair the most okay I might go with this one there's a
lot of that I thought this game look kind of ugly I don't
know I think it's got mod to make it a different there's
actually a mod for it to make it like i think i've seen more
like modded content of this game oh yeah i look like that
yeah i saw someone was like we could put creepers i almost
downloaded creepers into our server i i was just like oh my
god i can have a creeper in my server that would have raised
a lot of questions i would have been like what fucking game
is this what the fuck okay i kind of have my dogs out what
do you think i have your dogs out yeah all right why the
fuck okay why the do i have like why why do i am i like oh
okay it's this i was gonna say how do i be clean shaven why
do i have like a fucking like a homer stash how do i take
better care of my health oh my god look at my toes maybe i
should not your toes kind of disgusting do not take your
shoes off why not are you are you shaming are you shaming
really up my feet they look really shaming yes because i
think if it doesn't look right you should shut it off what
do you mean they don't look right They're all every you've
ever seen like a box aren't you you are not inclusive at all
a box of tissues?
Oh, that's what you mean Why the fuck do I still have a five
o'clock shadow?
What is wrong with my face?
Yeah, I have some reasons I can recommend for you.
I like the crown Wait, I want to she gained that five o
'clock shadow just from trying to like start to set up this
fucking server up Yeah, honestly
Oh, wait, there's so much, so many hats.
Big hug and kiss.
There's so many hats.
Oh, my God.
There's like a Pokemon.
Oh, there's a one-piece hat.
What the fuck?
What?
There's a one-piece hat in this game.
Yeah, I'm going to grab a crown.
Oh, wait, no.
Or the straw hat.
Oh, right.
The Luffy hat.
Yeah, yeah.
Yeah.
Wait, what the fuck is this?
Ear accessory.
Oh, are these earrings?
Oh, they are.
yeah just your ear or your yeah yours in general there's
earrings in this this kind of look like raccoon ears chad um
when you see like oh i see what you mean yeah no those those
feet ain't right no never mind those feet ain't right i
support you the inclusivity there's a point you know there's
a there's a point where you're like that ain't right abs
sick that's sick i got me some abs okay now i i don't oh my
gosh now i'm like i don't know if this this definitely does
not look like me i'm strong i know this looks like me if i
was like a guy online character i think yeah something
something about this it looks kind of like gaia did i feel
like the stretch that's true that's yeah that's what the
style reminds me of where these like oh yeah that looks like
i definitely need to sleep there we go my feet freak me the
out i love it oh my god i look like some sort of little
creature i look disgusting what the my hands are huge too
jesus i look like i'm about to rip somebody in there nice i
don't even want to wear clothes i just want to show my abs
it's what if i if i have it i gotta show it you know you're
gonna make me think of heated rivalry yeah i gotta flex what
i have you know i just gotta i'm gonna i'm gonna eye you
down up and down yeah wait who's the senpai and who's uh
who's the okay and who's the see me i don't forget see me
there's the uke and there's the cb use chat i think i'm the
uke whatever whichever one that one was okay okay the uke
and the see me oh i got a vest you know i'll put that vest
on The vest is nice.
I have a scarf on because it's cold.
Wait, should I put the scarf on or the vest?
I was like, oh, it's cold.
Let me just put the scarf on.
That should cover it up.
Oh, wait.
I get water floaters.
I won't drown.
They're going to be dripped out.
Wait, I need to put more accessories on.
Why are you so dripped out?
Okay, wait, wait.
Yeah, because I paid $60.
Oh, yeah.
That's why.
It's sort of like me.
Okay, I put stuffy down a little bit.
What chat, you hate me.
No, they don't, I hate you.
Okay, all right, all right.
That means I should just be louder than I'm going to turn my
own mic up.
Your enemies to lovers, you know, that's like, that's Eden
rivalry.
That's a cool one.
They literally, it's literally Team Russia versus Team
Canada.
Like, they literally, Russia literally took Alaska from us.
And it sold it to the United States.
That's what heated rivalry.
That's episode one of heated rivalry.
It starts sort of like the Fallout Alaska DLC.
Like, how dare you sell Alaska?
We shall solve this with hockey.
What's your room number?
I'm about to make you see what happens when you take Alaska.
Oh, what happens when you take Alaska?
Oh, what could you possibly do?
Oh, my God.
Oh, wait, wait, wait.
Does this hat, wait, this hat gives me ears.
Oh, it's a little short though for me.
Wait, I got some steel boots.
I got some knee pads.
So when I fall, I won't get hurt.
Oh, okay, no, you're right, bro.
This, I do not like it when he shows hurts his toes.
That ain't right.
What the fuck is this?
Oh, is this a cape?
Oh, my God.
Wait, that looks sick.
I feel like you're going to load up and be like a mall cop
or whatever.
Not a mall cop.
A mall samurai.
That's what it is.
Oh, you'll see.
You'll see.
All right, guys.
You're like your Naruto headband.
Your water floaties.
You're going to have some, like, a leather coat.
All right, guys.
Do I go?
Okay.
Oh, all right.
Wait.
Wait, which one?
Oh, all these cape looks sick.
Okay, guys.
One, two, three.
What are you counting?
Or you'll see.
You'll see.
One, two, or three.
Three?
Your abs?
Yeah, I know.
It's sick, right?
Sick as hell.
Three?
I see more threes.
All right.
I think I'm good to go.
It was just no neck mean.
Okay, I like it with the neck.
All right.
Save.
I'm ready.
Are you ready?
Okay, I think I am too.
Yeah.
Let me go into the server.
I need to...
All right, don't show the screen when you connect, by the
way.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Because of the IP address.
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
you see me wait you're oh my god you would unleash the tool
part of like the zelda cd oh my god like my abs yeah yeah
dude yeah i work up yeah you look like you should be on like
a side scroller video game from like 1993 i don't know why
it looked like I could hire on epal.com What the hell is
epal?
What the chat?
What does that mean?
What is epal?
What is she insinuating?
Look up epal.com.
Okay, okay.
Look it up.
I'm gonna search it up right now.
Epal.
Yeah, your kind teammates.
Epal.gg?
Just like PayPal.
Epal is a epal.
Congratulations.
Your first order free.
Is this boosting?
Oh my god!
Do I look like I'm going to get boosted?
No, you look like...
I'm just looking for a duo queue.
So...
You mean DPS?
DPS.
DPS used to be eGirl.gg.g.
Where you could hire eGirls to play with you.
But they got a lot of flack for it.
So they renamed it as ePAL.
So they don't even boost you.
They probably like put you into the negatives.
I mean, they could bring a friend.
apparently you could bring a friend yes oh my god one bring
a guy and then the the guy that won't be in the car the guy
that won't be in the car but the e-pal will be in the car
with you that's an insane reach around of just like i'm
playing with a girl but then she invited her big strong
boyfriend to also boost me at the same time so i'm giving
all the benefits but don't worry don't worry he's not in
cars so it's like do you have to pay for the two bodies like
you pay for the you guys it's like buy one get one free you
know you think about it let's buy one get one free i ain't
paying for no man i need to get rid of i got the mushrooms
oh i hate the bobbing if i'm getting rid of the wait give me
a sec i'm gonna change head bobbing yeah i gotta get rid of
that i hate that in general that sounds like a good idea i'm
gonna do that too yeah wait there's definitely in video it
says full screen if you if you didn't see that wait there is
to be in the game oh my god there is okay guys i got full
screen chat how cool is epic hightail graphics at any can i
max my view distance too like i think you should be able to
i think the view distance is already pretty high oh my god
if you switch to epic it's very high okay mine was on medium
mine is on medium too i'll do it high i'll do high and then
high and then i'm gonna have a 50 90 so i might as well like
what's the point i have in 50 90 if i don't do that all
right all right let's learn where did you find the head
bobbing setting oh it's on settings gameplay and then uh you
scroll down it's on camera um oh i can do third person too
wait i can't do third what the fuck how the fuck do i third
person oh on spawn okay wait never mind switch camera oh
shit i got candle what happens if you press oh yeah press v
you go to third person oh wait really oh shit i do oh my god
my hair is clipping that's gonna drive me crazy i can't look
at myself i got a bald spot oh my other me wait you actually
oh wait no you don't i don't i actually have all my hair
yeah yeah i'm balding for being like poor what do they call
it for not wanting to that's why you have a hat on oh this
is how you had your bald spot is my toupee i beat up this
tree you know in minecraft when you first boot up you beat
up a tree right off the bat you look so cool i don't know i
should have paid 60 dollars and i just look like an e girl
that somebody would pay yeah i paid for you you're my e-pal
um i'm on my e-pal date right now guys oh my god paying for
my e-pal ds yeah yeah i went i went e-pal and switched up i
was like hi you should change your stream title to that
e-pal collab let's go e-pal collab yeah all it took was
thank you oh thank you thank you what else am i good at um i
didn't pay you to stop oh um you're so good at opening and
launching games and starting servers oh thank you you're so
funny you're just like i don't know here here watch this
look at Look at this.
I don't like the way you hold.
Look at this.
How cool is that?
Come on.
Oh, I thought you were slamming your butt into the tree.
Yeah, yeah, that's right.
Yeah, you like that?
Yeah, you like...
She knows how to mine her wood.
That's right, girl.
Why is radio head playing?
Now, holy.
This is the most random song to play Hytale with.
I'm so sorry, Chad.
Is this Ren a girlfriend in real life?
No, because then the girl...
The girl would spend, like, was it, 600 chapters, like, not
getting together with the main character?
Wait, where did we go?
Oh, wait, is it here?
Wait, there's a structure over here.
That must be the main area.
Oh, yeah, there's bad guys over there, too.
Wait, wait.
There's so many things to see.
Wait, you want to see the bad guys?
Yeah, yeah, I want to see the bad guys.
Yeah, I'm renting a raccoon.
That's huge.
I think it's a skelly, man.
Look at how blood rose.
okay go no hero wait noble knight here i got you something
he's a poisonous oh bad blood rose oh wow what do i do with
this oh i don't know this is some sort of where's the evil
frog how do you know the frog is evil you don't know that
it's coming see that frog ate evil look at him he's a pussy
look at that oh he looks evil he looks he looks like Do you
take damage?
Wait, oh, PvP is not on, unfortunate.
Damn.
Unfortunate.
Wait, come get this guy.
Come beat this guy up.
All right.
Oh, I got an essence of life.
I don't want to know what that does.
You're going to need it after this guy.
Yeah, that's right.
Bam, bam, bam.
I think I just unlocked some sort of tech.
Yeah, look at this.
Oh, my God.
Look at this go.
Is this like, yeah, is this like Minecraft where you do
damage if you're in the air?
Yeah, yeah, like, be like, like the jump hit.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
I don't think that worked, but he launched me.
Wait, what is that?
Oh, is that turkey?
Oh, it's a turkey!
I don't think they have hunger yet in this game, because
it's early access.
Oh, yeah.
Oh, my God, they look, they look like Casar eyes.
They look terrifying.
Oh, my God, he loves that.
He loves it when you hit him.
Whoa.
Did he?
No, I think you accidentally fed him something.
I didn't feed him anything other than this fucking right
hook.
Oh, my God.
I think he was saying he was like kissing his girlfriend.
Goodbye, dude.
He just ended this family.
It's just like, please tell my wife.
He was like, I'll draw aggro.
Wait, I can't hear anymore.
Wait, oh, oh, she just disappeared.
All right, let's go to that.
There's a main fortress over there.
I assume that's like where we have to go in general.
I assume.
Wait, do you know how to build?
Do you know how to make houses?
We need a crafting block.
wait but like but like in minecraft do you know how to make
houses yeah you put a bunch of blocks down okay that's good
okay then you're in charge of that four by four don't worry
you're like you're like the the oh my god you're the
gatherer and i'm the hunter you know i just set off like a
land mine that's crazy there's a land mine here this game
has everything wait tab oh there is a crafting thing oh if
you press tab you can craft stuff now well i'll craft a
sword yeah yeah because i'm the hunter and then there's
chest there's campfire there's torches what is over here
though so apparently eating is just uh it's just to heal so
you're not like uh so you're not like ash oh my god that's a
wolf that's a wolf oh it's okay he's just okay don't worry
my lady i shall defend us you don't know where i am but
don't worry i'm defending you right now i feel very safe i'm
eating my berries and i'm i'm farming for us oh yeah what
are you farming girl uh i'm farming wheat i don't even know
i'm just eating these berries oh my god there's oh i'm
bringing up the game a little more these piggies are so cute
oh yeah they're cute can't believe it the cow is kind of
horrible okay the berries barely do any heals i found you oh
my god let me slaughter these piggies where did you get a
sword did you crack yeah you press tab you can start
crafting all right so you just you my lady you craft the you
craft the hatchet and the pickaxe plant as you are the And
I'm here to defend us.
I'm not a combat class.
What is over here?
Wait, there's a fortress here.
Got a dude.
Come here.
There's like a little fortress thing here.
Oh, hey!
There's a temple.
Yeah, there's a temple.
Look, there's a beautiful woman here.
What?
Where?
Don't get jealous now.
The rival girl what the hell don't there's plenty of jokie
to go around don't get jealous girl oh my gosh wait what's
this oh shit what the fuck i altered whoa yeah you did like
a con yeah all right raw me stupid woman
i meant the statue
what doki what there's some wild stuff down here oh shit oh
wait i think he's guard do you think that that guy's evil
forgotten temple gateway is what it says on my map i think
we can like that's wait wait there's a chest too can you
like hold aggro okay i will go gather and he can do the
combat you're right my kitchen i shall protect us You
don't...
Wait, can you... Is there sneak?
Wait, look at this.
Look, I'm about to take this under his damn nose.
You won't even know.
Don't worry, my kitten.
I shall defend this.
Hyrule chest.
Whoa, wait, small chest.
Oh, I got crude daggers.
Oh, yeah, what did I...
I got a crude hatchet.
Wait, I heard, like, the dagger shit is, like, OP.
Because there's, like, a...
A dash that you can do.
Are you ready?
I'm going to aggro and you go through that portal, I believe
in you.
you okay okay okay but did you get what did you get that
last chest there's another one or this one yeah yeah yeah i
got it all right i'm ready okay all right go go to the port
go to the portal go to the portal my kitten okay oh my god
there's fall there is fall damage oh my god i think i got
Oh, you look cool.
Yeah, I look sick as hell.
Oh, hey.
Whoa.
Where are we?
I have no idea.
This is freaking awesome.
Oh, God.
There's little men.
Oh, and they love us.
Oh, really?
They're chill.
Oh, I can't kill them.
Don't do it.
I can't kill them.
They're fellow players.
And there's like little monies and little deos.
Oh, and they're all so happy to see us.
Oh, my God.
Are you happy to see us?
Wait, this is a no-kill zone.
My job is obsolete here.
What can I do if I can't kill?
No, I can't kill anybody.
Oh, my God.
What's the point?
We live in peace.
Oh, my God.
A traitor.
We...
This is a society, dude.
I mean, it's like a little...
It's a town.
Oh, my God.
What the fuck is wrong with you?
You can have a construction sign for a construction sign.
There was.
Spices, salt, dough.
Ooh, they have skill.
Oh, that's what life essence are for.
Oh, I see.
Essence of life.
You can't pick this up.
You can't pick it.
Yeah, I picked up an essence of life.
I don't know how I picked it up, though.
Stupid peace.
What the fuck am I going to do with peace?
Oh, sleeping is disabled because time is paused.
Will there never be a motorcycle?
is paused.
I think there's no night in here.
I think that's fucked up in general.
This is literally the best place ever.
I think that's like pretty messed up.
You can never sleep ever.
You have unlocked the memories.
Rest within.
What the hell is going on?
What?
I'll record a memory.
What did I record?
Oh, I guess when you... A deity rests within the heart of
Orbus.
Seek out memories of Orbus.
Myriad creatures to record them to restore her I guess it's
like when you grab items you can put it here to unlock more
stuff I think yeah I can record two more memories I the only
memory I have is a frog I mean these are like people we
encounter oh it's like all the things we've encountered and
it'll unlock more stuff but we're still gonna encounter here
a lot of memories I guess that's like the Oh it's like
enemies and Oh enemies and animals okay Hello I've
encountered I've encountered you I've collected the bunny Oh
yeah how do you encounter the bunny You just like walk up to
it and then be like Memory recorded Because I like put it in
my brain I've absorbed it in my Brain space I'm cataloging
him with my photo memory Yeah like it's crazy with your eyes
you can like you can like absorb details about other people
duck i feel like i was just born minnow duck what is this is
that uh what is this uh four life is so beautiful i'm
witnessing you i'm witnessing
like horns it's a jackalope it's a jackalope all right i
recorded six memories i need like one more what else can i
record here in this little village you have a squirrel there
were squirrels squirrels there's like one more villager i
haven't encountered yet i feel like i've i feel like i've
seen everybody there's like owls flying around where the
hell are we are we supposed to get here i don't even know
how to leave you squirrel wait where's the squirrel why
would you ever want to leave this is heaven on earth my perk
i have no purpose here i have no purpose i must leave you're
a killer there's no retirement for people like me
check the birds flying around how the do i get to the birds
to literally fly I know, I'm like trying to climb.
What the hell is that thing?
I guess I can use my daggers.
Bro, how the fuck do I get to the birds?
They're just flying.
Oh my god, you can like parkour in this game.
That's crazy.
There's like one more like citizen here that I haven't met
yet, but I don't even know how to meet him.
Oh wait.
It's a butterfly memory?
Butterfly.
Oh, I found!
I found a squirrel!
Okay, I can unlock the first thing.
But I unlocked the squirrel.
I'm trying to get to the birds, but they're flying away from
me.
Yay!
Okay, so I have...
Oh, okay, craft!
Alright, let's leave.
We should find a home.
Should we, like... I feel like we should, like, live close
here because there's, like, in this area.
I didn't dash cancel?
How do I dash cancel, guys?
I know that...
What the hell?
dash canceling yeah there's dash canceling what the hell the
combat meta all right stuffy i'm waiting for you outside the
portal i'm trying to get to the birds oh my god wait wait
wait wait did you do it it's not worth it it's not worth it
no no i'm really high up though where are you oh i saw you
where are you i'm in the opposite direction i'm like on top
the temple what the how the did you get up there oh i see
you you're like oh no that's a duck i was like there you are
oh never mind that's just a duck yeah i don't think i can
where the oh my god wait are you all the way up there how
the fuck did you get up there oh they fixed the dash cancel
there's like parkour oh you can't dash
Oh wait, there's no, there's no, wait, there's no fall
damage here.
Oh, there is, but not here.
This is a place of peace, which is very boring.
That's crazy.
Stupid peace.
We should live here.
I don't think we can put stuff down, though.
No, we can't take anything for anything down.
There's no point.
Okay, wait, ooh, let me record my memories.
Wait, a butterfly.
Wait, that doesn't count.
Don't worry, my queen.
I shall be on the other, I shall protect us on the other
side of the portal.
Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, yeah, oh, my God, I forgot
about the golem.
I forgot about the golem.
It's okay.
Thank you, my noble knight.
Don't worry, I've aggroed him.
I also got a bucket.
I'm coming in.
Hello?
Oh, my God.
Oh, my God, oh, my God, oh, my God, oh, my God.
See, you're fat.
You're so healthy.
That guy's not even a threat.
I know, right?
So you're too slow.
Oh, there's a fox.
Wait, there's like double jumping.
That's fucking right.
What you gonna do?
All right.
Oh, there you are.
There's like a parkour segment here.
Wait, really?
I think I'd be really good at that.
Where is it?
It's like above us.
god i almost it's here i got this boom look at that i
defended you didn't get his oh wait no i did get his memory
i stared at his dead body oh oh my god oh my god wait wait
wait wait wait wait wait i need you to aggro i'm so i'm so
low i need you to aggro him i'm i'm picking him to death i'm
picking him to death he doesn't even care about me yeah he
doesn't care about you he's like woman He sees your cape
like a bull.
Oh shit.
Focus this guy.
He bought skins.
Dude, I don't think this is the play.
He's not.
I'm doing one damage.
How much HP?
Holy shit.
Oh my god.
Wait, let me loot all your stuff.
I see loot all my stuff.
Fuck.
Did you hit him like 20, like 30 times?
and he was still alive how do i where are you where are your
dual blades no um i think a server is set up so that you
don't lose everything you'll lose like half your stuff oh my
god i should go back to heaven dude that wolf was locked in
guards guards blow this guy's balls up please oh my god i'm
coming over okay i found sanctuary within the troll people
the what people oh my god you fucking absorbed all my that's
god man wait where are you all right that's it round two i'm
i'm still near the temple there's just like a bunch of trees
round two fucking stupid ass wolf i need more food that that
stuff hurts oh my god wait how fucking tanky is what okay so
that wolf was like had to be the strongest dog i've ever
seen that is the strongest wolf in the game it is like
literally like it's like a secret boss fight i refuse to
believe he's not a secret boss fight i just encountered that
would be crazy if there was like an rg mechanic we can just
like yeah the strongest like random the strongest wolf to
ever live apparently you're not worth shit if you don't have
any essence of life so yeah i mean i had 20 on me i think
you took the other half when i died oh my god i do have the
other half yes where are you i'm in the big tree is by the
gray stuff do you see it big tree big tree I thought this
was you.
Oh, I see you.
I see you.
I see you on the map.
Alright, I'm coming over.
Alright, we gotta find a home, Snuffy.
We can't keep...
We can't keep wandering.
Oh, wait!
Wait, there is a town here.
There's a villager.
I've seen mice.
Wait, did you go to the little village?
Oh, yeah, you are there.
Okay, okay.
Yeah, we gotta... We gotta... We gotta make a home.
Oh, shit.
what have you done my home oh my god oh i forgot you you
couldn't attack the NPCs in heaven dude you couldn't take a
wolf and you took a grown man um a grown woman
is this a woman i meant the guy no no i no this is not my
first murder get him what that's looking right
Oh my god!
Did he give you his essence of life?
No, they don't give anything.
You could probably trade it into like his...
I killed him for free.
I killed him for the fun of it.
Oh, look, see, they're fine.
See?
They're okay.
You just took all that stuff.
Wait, you can take this?
Yeah.
And you don't even care.
You don't even care.
Free essence of life?
Oh my god.
Look at that.
You still want to trade...
Oh, they're like trading villagers.
They don't even give good shit, though.
Oh my god, look at these.
Oh my god, we have...
You don't even know!
What's this?
Okay, I'll build a big, strong house for you, my knight.
Oh, I have a little child.
No, Doki, please!
Not the children.
Where is she?
Oh my god, they're hiding in their homes.
They're on lockdown, dude.
Are they really locked down?
Where are they?
Where are the other villagers?
This guy is not leaving his house.
He saw what I did.
They're hiding from me now.
No witnesses.
Should we not live near these people?
I don't think they respawned.
I don't know where we could build a good house.
They're not all.
No.
There's like something cool over here.
Wait.
Oh my god.
There's a bed.
I stole one of your hat beds for myself.
What's your favorite part of the game so far?
I don't know.
No, I think the combat's fun.
The combat's pretty fun.
I haven't got even a combat weapon yet.
Don't worry, Kitson.
You don't need a fight ever again.
This game hurts.
I think I'm too, here's some Minecraft.
This is like, you're going to come in here expecting
Minecraft and then they're going to...
I mean, it feels like Minecraft.
terraria and minecraft that's how i feel it's like a 3d it
feels like 3d terraria i think wait game up a bit more okay
i'll put the game more i think the game itself is just like
pretty quiet yeah all right did you get did you hear if you
pick your nose there's more chance you'll get alzheimer's
what yeah i'm so gone there's no one of my memories so bad
dude there's like like the new a newest study came out like
recently where like people who pick their noses more will
most more likely develop alzheimer's what yeah why is it
because you're tickling your brain or something it's like
some i don't it was like a harvard study like recently a
harvard study yeah that's fucking hilarious what do you
think they study just like they invited a bunch of people to
like sit in a room and start picking their nose you pick
your nose yes don't lie yes i'm gonna go to this like mill
over here this looks cool we should live in the mill oh we
should we don't have to build stuff we can just live there i
want to sign up dude i literally think that all the time
whenever i hear about these studies is i'm constantly like
dude why did nobody ask me like i want to be of a study i
want to pick the only part of the sample size yeah i don't
want to just be an organ donor i want to be a scientist too
i want to i want to help i think you might need a phd for
that to be to be a subject no oh but you said you wanted to
be a scientist well like by association because i'm also
helping it's like being mojo jojo to like the professor he
considered himself smart i mean it's through the study where
he got the oh my god this sun is going down um joki the sun
is going down and the skeletons are casting fireballs oh
that is not good i think we might need a house oh i'm okay
i'm okay um i'm climbing up high for safety um let me eat
some apples oh that's the moon oh okay i'm in the what is
that i was gonna say i was like oh that's sweet that you'd
like the the candle for me but that was not you i don't even
know where you are that was that was oh the skeleton has a
oh my god the rat okay what the hell it's fine everything is
okay okay it's okay oh my god oh it's okay it's okay if
you're worried about me don't worry i'm
Isn't that okay over there?
What the fuck is going?
They saw my rooes.
They saw into my rooes.
What is going on up there?
I'm stuck down here.
Oh, that's so pretty out there.
You're stuck up here.
I'm coming.
Wait, are you back in the village?
No, I'm still in the cave.
I never left the cave.
What do you mean a cave?
What do you mean?
I'm in the fucking cave.
No, that was in a cave.
what do you mean what do you what do you game why is this
glowing oh probably oh wait the wolf is still there i'm
going back wait were you in the you you went to the the art
the archive cave or whatever the way how do i fuel this i'm
like i'm like fighting for my life right now i'm making some
food yeah did you die no i'm still i'm still in the middle
system for like oh the i was on top of the mill you did you
go down in the hole yeah the hole oh oh what is that how did
we how did things die um i pushed them off okay how did you
how did you get that did you just jump down there oh wow you
can climb the chain i can climb the chain okay but i can't
it's not prompting me to do that okay there's no prop
there's no problem it's just you just gotta believe you just
gotta believe everything is fine oh my god where'd you go
i'm i'm here you just gotta believe so pretty right now man
just gotta let me eat the meat real quick
um how did you push people oh my god he didn't want to get
pushed he did not he did not want to get pushed i'm trying
to get oh my god oh my god okay i got him i got him i got
him everything is fine you just gotta believe i'm oh my no
no no no no no no no no no no no no hello um it's okay
everything is fine everything i feel like i'm playing one of
them did you ever play like the handheld donkey con game or
actually i think it was like n64 donkey con or whatever or
you just like hold on to like yeah you grab stuff i don't i
forget what that was so i would get my thinking of donkey
con hoops or something the donkey god what the fuck you are
you talking about no not dk64 i don't think it was oh king
of swing I think it was king of swing.
I have never heard of that game.
Oh my god.
I'm fucking dead.
I'm fucking dead Oh, oh, they're so bad.
That is rats you too.
Just go up.
Just go up dude.
Just go up I'm gonna eat real quick Why don't you just just
just just go to the safe part just come up here higher Did
you rotate?
I'm gonna bash this wood and create my own my own little
cubby hole.
Can you not can you not like oh you can no no i'm like stuck
here okay i figured it out i gotta make my hole oh my god
that's not the right one i just gotta keep bashing yeah
there's dudes like everywhere yeah there's a lot of dudes
around me
hey don't worry it's almost there we're almost there right
here it's okay there you go that was the wrong thing okay i
might be able to help hold on okay wait wait i have some
carrots oh my god oh my god we're going through so much
right now wait wait wait wait i have an idea wait wait wait
i got you i got you i got you come on oh my god my hero oh
my god the rose have swapped oh my god the rose swap
okay oh my god why are there two skeletons here that's why i
haven't gone up okay don't worry the rose has swapped yet
again i saved you my queen have you killed this evil okay
these guys are like oh we're so easy to kill never mind all
right let's find a home we still need to find a place to
live wait can i still these people's beds oh my god i'm
pretty sure you can right i'm gonna craft them dokey the war
makumi there's a there's an urchin the war i got you dude
you would have just killed that would be uh 20 per boost uh
my kda averaged uh over three extra 15 dollars holy we're at
it all these fucking creatures there's a fucking spot next
to our house this is we don't live here whoa but you're
getting so much loot yeah i'm sad i'm already like i don't
have a lot of uh a lot of space anymore i feel like i should
get rid of some of these things in my inventory i'm gonna
get rid of the dirt and oh my god get rid of the dirt space
how do i need three stone to craft a crafting a mole rat oh
my god what the fuck is that oh oh he's like magic a
skeleton mage oh a dead skeleton mage oh my there's another
here don't worry my queen i got you thank you every slash is
ten dollars um dude you are really worth it i'm gonna read
you yeah yeah remember to give you five stars um and a
review on my e-pal uh gg site uh yeah i would totally get a
lever really appreciate it
oh wait there's something yeah there's someone down here oh
was it just life essence okay wait i gotta build i gotta i
can't get distracted we gotta build okay i can oh i can put
this on my other arm way oh my god a goblin a goblin are
they good goblins or bad goblins oh i got workbench he looks
bad i don't like his vibes yeah yes my queen you want me to
want me to kill him my kitten look he's over here yeah all
right don't worry look at him goblin scrapper don't worry
kitten i got you no one shall look at my women like that
there's another house over here maybe we should just like
live on the water just like water is useful what the would
water do for us though i don't know like for drinking do we
need to drink water she's kidding for the vibes 100 how do
you get it says it is stone but i'm picking up stone i think
it's stone rubble i don't think that's the i don't think
that's the actual stone stone cobblestone oh it's a mine
cobblestone yeah did you hear about the marvel rivals drama
that's everywhere right now the last thing i saw about
marvel rivals was like a disco skin where is like oh yeah
with thor yeah yeah yeah apparently there's a new drum okay
so it's basically a tournament um it got super mainstream
that like uh moist critical made a video about it and like
people everywhere are talking about it just the one that
like just happened yeah just like the two last two days oh
my god yeah and then like so basically what happened was
this guy um he it's really funny because one of my friends
was the substitute for this guy so What happened was this
guy got kicked out of the tournament, a $40,000 tournament,
because he had a Widowmaker one trick on his team, like the
sniper one trick on his team, and he asked her to swap off.
And then three other...
Did you say Widowmaker?
Oh, sorry, not Widow.
Black Widow.
Oh, my God.
Black Widow on his team.
And then, long story short, they refused to swap.
They did not refuse, but like three...
of the teammates ganged up on him being like yeah like we're
just gonna let her play widow um like and then he's like
please i really want to win this recall like i'm a broke
college student i really need the money so like the higher
placement you get the but then like and then the widow's
boyfriend i really need the money yeah yeah um it was like
really fucked up because um and like if you ever if you make
tweets about it you get like super engagement bait like
everyone who made ton of likes and retweets and everything
about it.
And, yeah, and also the Black Widow had 200 ping because she
was playing from Australia.
So, wait, did they carry?
The whole thing was they didn't want them to play Black
Widow.
He doesn't want her to play Black Widow.
Like, through?
He didn't want her to play Black Widow, so, like, the Black
Widow's boyfriend got him kicked out of the tournament
because he tattled on him.
He tattled on him to the tournament organizers.
He'd be like, Wait, wait, wait, what was the issue?
Like, what did he do?
They were trying to...
Okay, so, like, the most fucked up part was when my friend,
Moxie, he was, like, substituting for Kingsman.
Like, that's the guy.
The guy that got kicked out, his name is Kingsman.
And then he was...
Wait, wait, wait, wait.
Come here.
Really quick.
There's something in the distance.
What the fuck is that?
Is it flying towards us?
I don't know.
So what's fucked up was that my friend Moxie was the one
that was substituting for him.
and then is he getting closer no wait what the fuck is that
you yeah that's disgusting it looks like a beholder yeah it
looks like that dungeon dragon thing yeah yeah yeah and then
anyway and then i asked him i was like oh wait i thought you
weren't in the tournament like oh i didn't get invited to it
like how do you get in this last minute he's like oh i was
substituting for kingman because um apparently like he was
implying that he was like super he was like sexist or
whatever to the girls and now i was like oh that's sucks,
buddy.
Like, I mean, like, I was like, oh, that sucks, but at
least, like, you know, you get to play.
And he's like, yeah.
And then apparently, and then it got exposed that the girls
lied about him being sexist.
And he was actually just like, he got kicked out.
Yeah.
So like, I first while I was like, well, that's, that's
fucked up.
Like, why was he so sexist towards the women?
And then later on he made an expose video about the, his
team.
Like, like the day before the tournament, um, the day, yeah,
that's the thing that no one, like, no like no one really
knows about that i was told of um because like they were
like spreading rumors about kingsman and stuff because like
that's what i thought happened at first because kingsman
didn't make his video yet and then um yeah and then he they
uh he made a video exposing the entire the not the entire
team but like half the team and basically um basically it
blew the first came out it had 40k views and now and now the
video has almost i think it's like 600k views the last time
i saw this was from two days ago this was two days ago by
the way this was this was two days ago and then yeah i was
like holy i dodged a bullet by not participating in that
tournament because my friend moxie was like oh yeah you want
me to get you in i can i can ask him to get you in i was
like no that's i was like no it's okay it's still last
minute i don't really want to join a tournament that last
minute and i'm like oh thank god i was so like half the
girls careers are basically over because what yeah because
every ending tournament the amount of times i can count
these on my fingers yeah it was literally a career ending
tournament like it was like like um it was really funny
because like um bulgar there's another tournament coming out
next week like that's going to be starting next week um and
then the tournament organizer it's called for those who
don't know it's boga bash too and then um and then uh boga
was like do you want to be captain and i was like no i i
want to avoid the cc i don't want to do a cc that's the
girl's name by the way the captain cost most of the drama
and i was like i don't want to do a repeat of that yeah i
was like no i i was like i would like to be a player i do
not i'm that's crazy what the hell and because like she was
also the girl she got twitch banned for a day like yeah
because she she said she said uh keep yourself safe but like
the actual the actual what do you mean keep yourself safe
the first yeah yeah but but not keep yourself oh my god i
was like that doesn't sound so bad why would she be in for
like yeah yeah yeah she said keep yourself safe but but not
but only the letters only the letters and she got she got
one day banned on twitch one day yeah that's crazy yeah and
she was like um i said it to my friend like and she kept
like she kept digging a d-pole and she was like um I said it
to my friend like I was trying to send that to my cat that
was not meant to be on stream and then Kingsman revealed
that the random person she said it to doesn't even know her
she was like I'm not even friends with this person what the
fuck does she mean dude I'm convinced these tournaments are
some sort of like insane like it's like I used to do like
like twitch rival stuff and whatnot and I kind of got the
vibe that it can be super like unbalanced yeah because like
okay the whole thing was that yeah the whole thing was that
the girls were like we're just playing for vibes and then
the one guy was like bro i really want to win like this is
40 000 and then this is for fun like you don't and then the
team captain was like called him a broke loser and was like
yeah and i was like bro what like even for me dude what the
Yeah.
Like, even for me, like, I...
Yeah, what were you going to say?
No, you first.
I'm going to have to watch the critical video.
Oh, you got to watch the video.
I watched all the videos because I was, like, there on
ground.
Like, not ground zero, but I was there on day one.
Oh, my God.
Wait, did you get...
You, like, like, lost the round and you didn't go to, like,
day two or something?
No, no.
Like, as in, like, my friend was supposed to be in the...
like my friend substituted for the guy that got kicked out
so that i was like so caught up on like and then i asked him
why he was something and then so then he was like oh yeah
like this is what they told me and i was like dude what the
i thought what the why is your sexist yeah and then later i
found out the girls were just spreading rumors why would you
even get so serious for like a like a freaking marvel rivals
stream tournament like that's crazy that's crazy actual like
ranked and stuff yeah like because it was like it's like a
lot of money for these people too so but it's like it's
crazy because it's like um um i the tournament organizer was
like to the guy that got kicked out he was like why are you
like do you care about money so much just go pro like why
the fuck are you like this is a creator tournament for fun
why are you participating and i'm like a creator hosted
tournament no it was like it was hat like there was like
some pro players in there and like some creators.
So it was like it was like 5%, 5 to 10% pros.
Oh yeah, like the nonsense type tournament.
Yeah, but then it'll be it's like very skewed on like the
thing is like pros barely make any money too.
So it's like that's just some what was the money reward on
this?
Also I'm sorry, I'm like enraptured by the detail of those.
Are you seeing those?
So like first place each player gets $3,000 which is a lot
for like a college student and like for five five people or
was it or six like split like um it's i don't remember it's
like three times six so each player themselves gets 3k oh
it's like every everyone gets paid for the tournament but
like first though that doesn't even seem like a ton like am
i crazy like i thought if you get first in those tournaments
it's like big money i think like three days a lot for like a
college student though in general is it really i mean yeah
that's like half of tuition isn't it that's half of tuition
that's that's still a lot yeah it's a lot i don't know i
feel like i mean i don't know i guess if you're if you're if
you play marvel rivals tournaments for money there's got to
be other opportunities for that not a lot for like i mean
like for like a big tournament you guys like like i said i'm
used to twitch rivals they always But those are like smaller
creators though.
That's the thing.
Twitch rivals, they only invite the big creators.
So like this guy was like a really small creator.
Because it was like 70% were like smaller creators.
And like 30 were like the big ones.
So like for me like I would for me it would be like I would
always forget about cashing in the money.
Because I'm in so many of these tournaments.
I don't know if you joined like non-twitch rivals, but
there's like so many forms You gotta like fill out and then
like tax forms etc to like get your money I've ever done
like a non-twitch tournament type thing but like I always
still try like no matter what In the tournament I still like
flex whatever they need me to play and I still try But it
was like crazy because like the the like three four of them
three or four of them were like just playing for fun it's
just for vibes so now it's a meme now they're like yeah
they're just like oh no are you gonna play for vibes okay i
gotta i gotta remember now if people say i'm just playing
for vibes i'll be like i know i know the reference now no
it's crazy it actually broke mainstream it like people
around like everywhere people who don't even play rivals are
talking it and the thing is the guy i think i saw like the
yeah the tweet like somebody tweet criticals video and
they're like this the you know the situation is crazy or
whatever yeah and now so i guess yeah that makes sense yeah
and like it's crazy because like because like the guy the
guy that got kicked out he he streamed for like the first
five minutes of his stream he he basically made 3k because
everyone was just donating and subbing to him and then like
apparently today he had 25k people watching him it was this
like very small streamer too he was like a he didn't even
have twitch partner at that time damn yeah so like they were
harassing him yeah the girls were harassing him oh what the
hell yeah because like because all he wanted he was just
trying to get her to get her to stop playing widow um
because he was like for a more winnable team invite more
winnable team fight you gotta stop playing and he's like and
he's like a rank one in that magic player anyway they could
have gotten bag yeah and then anyway so i got invited to a
tournament for next week for the boga bash too i might ask
boga i was like oh do you have because he announced this
other tournament and i was like oh do you still have stats
he's like oh i can make you a captain I was like, I do not
want to be in it.
But then he was like, oh, it's okay.
I'll give you, we're going to be assigning pro players.
So like during drafting, when we're drafting players, like
you can ask them to draft the players.
And I was like, oh, so like if I fuck up the drafting, I can
just blame the pros.
Because I was like, oh, God, zero kills five deaths, zero,
six in that match.
Oh my God.
Yeah, I could be like, I didn't pick this team.
players, pro players picked it.
I'm zero accountability.
I don't know what I'm doing.
Oh my god, that's crazy.
Especially because it wasn't even like, like I could
understand especially like if it was, because I only know
Twitch rivals, which is sometimes like, yeah, they can,
like, sometimes it's like good for content, you know, it's
not too sweaty, even though like pros get invited.
It's not, it's, it's mostly like a stream event.
It's like, no, but it's always like one, the two teams.
Invitational tournament.
It's always, but there's always, like, one to two teams that
try to, that are, like, super stacked, though.
Also, we should actually...
Hold on, wait.
I'm going to grab this bit.
I'll be right back.
Oh, you're going to get a drink?
Hold on.
One sec, chat.
No problem.
All right, anyway, so...
I put all my stuff in this chest, by the way.
Oh, wait.
Is this our new house?
I just figured we could live in here.
It's kind of chilling, right?
Yeah, yeah.
This is a good place to live.
You don't want to craft a chest, too.
Yeah, crafted chest.
I'm going to try and get a workbench and I'm back, but I'm
just...
Oh, I have a workbench already.
Yeah, I'll just put it here, then.
Oh, yeah, I'll put it here.
And then, can we stack chest or no?
I wonder.
Oh, we can.
Okay, that's good.
All right.
Oh, yeah, no.
It's crazy.
The drama is so crazy that, like, a basketball, like, what
is it, the Atlanta basketball team tweeted, like, made a
TikTok about it.
And also, like, I was talking to one of my friends.
Apparently, he was at the hospital getting something checked
out.
And, like, while he was in the waiting room, while he was in
the waiting room, people were, like, on their phones
laughing about the...
Laughing about the fucking Marvel Rivals drama.
And I was like, holy shit.
That's how mainstream it has become.
I was talking to Kony, and he was like, he doesn't give a...
Like, all he does, he plays...
He, like, play... He does play Rivals, but even he was like,
Okay, Doki, did you hear about the rival's drama?
And I'm like, the Kingsman video has 1.2 million views.
Guys, I saw that video when it was 40 KVs.
Yeah, it fucking went mainstream.
No, there is no way any of these girls can have a career
again.
There's no way.
Even then, like, if people see them in game, people are just
going to throw their games.
And then the tweet about, like, they set back women in
gaming sphere by 100 years.
I was like, no!
I'm just like, no!
No, I think, I think the most fucked up part was that one of
the girls that threw him under a bus was his consistent rank
duo.
I was like, how the fuck did you not defend him?
Like, I would be so fucking mad.
I always defend my duos.
And I'll be, like, so fucking mad if, like, my rank duo did
not defend me in the...
Oh, yeah.
Oh, my God.
What?
I was telling them how, like, one of the girls that was in
that drama was, like, the guy's duo partner in rank.
And she, like, threw him under the bus, too.
Dude.
I was like, that's fucked up.
Like, how do you play with this person consistently?
Like, he, like, literally boosted you, and you can't even
defend him.
They don't know what it's like to be a professional e-pal, I
guess.
Yeah, I was like, I was like, how could you not defend your
e-pal?
That's so messed up.
What do they think was gonna happen?
I thought, and they thought that they were, like, the guy
wouldn't make a video about it.
Like, he would just, like, suck it up and shit.
Good on them for sticking his guard, though.
Yeah.
Because, like, at first, like, at first, like, his friend
was, like, don't make a video about it.
up and go next and then he and then he made a video yeah go
next dude just suck up three thousand dollars just go next
you didn't lose anything of value i think if he never made
that video he would he would have like um because like i
because like you know the girls were telling rumors that he
was being super sexist towards them and like because like
that's what i heard the day before the tournament and so if
he didn't drop because i heard about it and it was like it
was like it was because like um that's what i was told
because i was like whoa you're subbing in for him what
happened and then and then the guy dropped the video and
everyone like found out that like they were spreading like
false rumors yeah do they get their money well i don't know
if the others got their money i just also think like i i i
like i don't know i like i just think the tournament itself
was very poorly organized in general damn i don't know if i
saw anybody playing on the tournament this is why i can't
trust any women now i'm upset it's okay don't worry i'm your
bro right you paid for my presence i can't jeopardize i'm
your bro it's okay chat i'm your bro yeah this is my bro
this is my duo i would never throw you under the bus wait
where did you go there's horses we there's horses look off
into the Oh my god, I heard you can just ride, you don't get
mad, you can just ride them.
You don't need a saddle?
Oh my god, this one has beautiful hair.
You also killed, they'll like run away, I think.
Oh wait, unless you, I guess they kind of have like emo boy
hair.
Oh my god, they do.
Get over here.
Nice.
Did they have like a defensive?
I don't think I can just run.
Can I?
The cows were like kicking me, so I just wanted to know if
they have like a kick button.
i don't think so i think they they'll kick oh i think like
they don't really do any i think because it's early access
all you can do is just ride it i keep walking in the
buildings and it just is work in progress with the hale it
is early access i thought the way everybody was enjoying
this game there has to be some sort of content maybe i'm
just getting like well there is a lot of content you just
gotta like it we just gotta leave here like advance to
somewhere yeah because there's like a lot of like regions
and stuff but it like i think people like it more when it's
like early access you know like i mean i when they play a
super modded version of this to give more content i guess
wait what's that is that lobster a lobster as a lobster and
then we also have to start oh my god there's like a freaking
map dang apparently horses can drown oh could they oh could
they not before is that like new horse oh my god bear like
you could like take him into the water and then the horses
will drown chat how do i get off the horse oh bear gaming
wait there's a bear oh he looks nasty you should fight me
outskill this guy i'm watching i think you're running away
no no no no he he why are you running away i flopped i
flopped can you show me how it's done all right don't worry
i got you i don't know how to carry games it's okay my
kitchen i got you so much two hits and you're dead two hits
and you're dead oh maybe he can also drown wait my horse run
away it was like see ya
i don't know if i was literally like if mojang had any
ambition at all to make minecraft a better game instead of
just adding more tile sets and systems that do nothing oh oh
get over here horse get over here oh my god that was my
horse what the hell okay okay okay you stab him and then
aggro him and then okay yeah you wait okay okay okay and now
come back oh my god yeah yeah yeah wait wait wait oh my god
i got him i got him okay okay that's good that's good that's
good we We got good strat.
We got good strat.
Teamwork.
Keep working.
Give me just hide and meet.
I mean, hide is pretty.
Like, meet is pretty good.
But I'm going to start.
I didn't even see what we could craft yet.
When we needed, like, did you have...
Did you do an axe or no?
Yeah.
I don't have an axe.
Yeah, I don't have a hatchet.
I only have a...
I only have a pickaxe.
I was like, what's the opposite of it?
An evil spider.
I can start mining.
I'm mining.
The wolves have swapped.
I'm poisoned, actually.
Wait, where did you go?
Oh, I see you.
Okay, that's me.
You're over there.
I'm by the horses.
Is this game like Minecraft where we're supposed to go
deeper?
exploration, I'm pretty sure.
Oh, I can make a...
Oh, I have a campfire.
We can, uh, we can, uh, light our, make our meat.
Well, now it's raining, so how are you gonna light it?
It's fine.
It doesn't follow its Minecraft rules.
It's high-tail rules.
Oh my god, the clouds look kind of scary.
It looks like someone just smudged a, like, texture in
Photoshop.
Yes, yeah.
I need to make more.
Yeah, you should cook some meat.
Deeper can have new lures, but it's more influenced by
further biomes.
What do I get?
Oh, I can pick it up.
Okay, nice.
I mean, we could dig down.
Let's do it.
I might dig straight down.
What's the worst that could happen?
A giant hole opens up below you and you fall to your death.
There's no way they have lava.
I think you're already too deep for me to commit,
unfortunately.
no jump jump down i'll catch you i'll catch you i'm gonna
take straight dad oh god here hold on don't worry my queen i
got the thick eyes yeah or guys or i can't see your big head
is in the way i got nowhere your big pay to win skull i'm
going down it has to be a cave somewhere what if our pickaxe
breaks then we craft another one how much do we need oh we
need plant five it's okay we can live how will we ever go
back that's for future doki and snuffy to worry about okay i
sure hope i don't have a running with future doki and snuffy
so i'm gonna have a few word with their decision-making is
there bedrock how far down can we go at 33 cobblestones oh
my god this is going nowhere
it's okay we can always chat we're testing the XYZ levels
yeah I feel like I'm having a seizure looking at oh my god
what you're right
Oh my pickaxe is freaking getting close to we we made it to
basalt basalt cobble oh my god we're at basalt cobble what
does that mean oh something's purple it's volcanic cobble oh
we're at volcano town
we don't have any plant fiber do you have plant fiber no I
think like this feels very lava yeah I will say I do see
like fire particles yeah maybe yeah maybe that's my torch it
could be anything I think it's your torch yeah well once
this breaks I have no way F7 is we're at rock volcano rock
where are you guys at oh we're at rock volcano you know yeah
you ever go that low before you ever hit rock a volcano um
i'm a little worried now we're not even gonna be able to
kill each other down here we're gonna be there's no
starvation dokey your crew pickaxe broke it's okay you have
dude there's no way we can die down here there's no way
right we've screwed ourselves we're gonna Jokey locked me in
the mines, guys.
I'm going to be stuck here now.
Yeah, but we're stuck here together.
Oh my god.
I can't go down any further.
It's not letting me.
Wait, no it is.
No, it is.
What are you talking about?
This looks like the scene from...
What was that?
Competitive heed or something?
Heated rivalry?
Competitive seed?
What the fuck are you?
Can you craft a new pickaxe?
Alright, don't worry, I got you.
I'll craft another pickaxe for you.
Okay, and this POV is crazy.
Don't worry, don't worry, my kid, and I'll craft you another
pickaxe.
Just give me a sec.
Are you going back up?
Take take your time out.
What the?
I'm just a rat in a cage.
There's no way I can get out now.
I guess you got a dig down.
You put so many above me.
I've been sentenced to death.
I guess I guess you got a dig down.
I might dig straight down.
Dude, I...
I feel like a mole person now.
My eyes are bad.
I can't do anything other than dig in my tunnels.
I don't hear any other voices.
I see the light.
Oh my god.
Wait, I see the light.
Yeah, you...
You used me as like a booster seed.
And now I'm literally buried under your 20 blocks of
cobblestone.
I see the light She's gonna build up I'm definitely I think
I'm not pretty sure This is more than 20 blocks I'm pretty
sure Don't worry I got you plant fiber Don't worry I got you
I'm a hero I got us plant fibers Don't worry Can't even find
me In the earth anymore Don't worry I shall save you For
land development Dude I was paved over When you guys go to
Doki Lawn You're gonna see My body Like covered in like
cement under the road somewhere it's like a like an indian
burial site like the haunted ones i literally just covered
it over yeah these are the uh the dokey mounds yeah the
cursed the cursed snuffy burial site okay i'm getting us
lots of plant fibers don't worry wait i need rubber how do i
get rubber Keep digging down, I'll save you.
Chad, should I keep digging down or should I just like go
left or right?
Keep digging down, I'll save you.
I just want to know what happens when you can't dig down
anymore.
Are you able to dig down with just your, like, hands?
Maybe it's more beneficial than the broken pickaxe, right?
No.
Oh, shit.
Really?
What are the rubble?
Oh, there it is.
Wait, is that?
What is that?
How do you even get a torch?
It's so dark.
What do I do?
Yeah, you can dig your hands.
You can dig your hands, Snuffy.
No, I cannot.
Okay, come down here and try and dig up some volcanic
bubbles through your hands.
They said it's possible.
I believe.
I believe in my chat.
Your chat's lying.
chat you're gonna have to fact check this pull up high tail
dot wiki make sure you're reading the most recent patch
notes yeah yeah yeah they say you cats because they they
look they think of the old patch in the new patch in the new
patch you can dig it matrix pill to like end it all oh what
do i do can i like point my sword back at me like how do i
end this wait is this the hole
oh i hope you perish down here i hope you find the wrong
hole in parish i i'm literally a hero right now a hero this
is a stage this is staged don't worry my queen i'm here to
save you i'm leaving a bad review on the e-pal this is wait
wait wait wait i'm i'm getting down right now
you are nowhere near me i know that no no no i'm being here
right now you're gonna be like oh my savior you came back
for me you're not even getting closer to me i can see you no
no okay you have to admit it's pretty far why is it so far
it's not we did dig for a very long time you're you're not
you're you're probably not even digging down you're just No,
I'm actually taking down that brightened up material for two
more to pick axes.
It says you're 70 meters away from me.
If you were above me, there would be zero.
Yeah, I'm right here.
I'm right here right now.
You have gotten two meters close.
And I'm getting two meters close again.
Oh, my God.
Look, see?
Chad, I don't think there's anything that happens when you
dig straight down in high tail.
There is.
There has to be a cave.
I think I think we were very unlucky.
There must be a cave down there.
What's the point?
There's always a cave.
You gotta be patient.
I just you gotta be patient.
Look see I'm almost there stuffy.
I'm tired boss.
I'm real tired.
Well, that's too damn bad.
You gotta keep digging.
No!
99% of miners quit before they hit the cave.
I don't think I'm ready to see light again when the hole,
like, finally opens right there again.
Wait, temple gateway?
Wait, that's where the portal was.
Oh, that's the portal?
Oh, okay, never mind.
But I see you.
Wait, really?
Where am I?
Wait, do I see you?
Wait, where are you?
I see light.
I told you!
Parish!
Oh,
shit, I'm taking all of the cobblestone and I'm getting the
fuck out of here, dude.
Oh, my God, how do I put it down?
How do I get out of here?
Good luck getting back home, you bitch.
yeah wow i'm on my way back don't worry about it i'll take
your items back to you my queen oh my god wait how do i how
do i go to my to the wait how the do i even like go to her
do you respond where we were no i didn't respond in the bed
oh wait did you sleep you didn't sleep i did sleep wait i
slept right next to you i don't remember I don't remember
that.
You didn't even come in on my toes.
You don't have enough rocks to come back up.
It says Little Raccoon's bed on the viewfinder.
Do you see like an icon for your bed?
Yeah, no.
I know where my bed is, but like, I have to walk so far.
Yeah, good luck.
Good luck getting out of that hole.
I ain't helping you.
I'm going to find that hole.
It's rather deep.
I'm going to find that hole and I'm placing more blocks down
there.
can't believe i might not actually make it out that's right
you're stuck yeah you're stuck just keep digging down you
just gotta keep digging down now there's no other way out of
here chat
oh my god how did i not have as many cobblestone to get out
of here as it took to get to get down here because i only
dropped half of it that's fucking right that's right you
didn't even drop
I crafted you I had all the materials you lost the RNG
Because I how do I how do I craft how do I repair something
chat?
I think you're right and now you read it, don't you?
No, you dropped your plant fiber.
What I'm back in it.
I'll just craft a new one
Can't see crop All right, oh my god, I know what to do
I know what to do.
Wait, there's like bunny hops in here.
That's crazy.
New memory collect.
Wait, there's a calf and a chick next to me.
Wait, there's a baby chick.
Oh my god, Draco, is that you?
Oh.
I killed it.
I wish I could see them.
Yeah, too bad.
Too bad.
You could have.
I should not do anything.
no no no no you can't no no no you knew what you were making
you knew what you're making now i dug in this hole with you
i i was right or die with you and you chose die you chose
die and then right away you were like those women in that
kingsman video you're just like them that's right that's
right get ready for that video i said my duo i was gonna
leave five stars i was gonna leave five stars on your page
that you were gonna I said I was gonna tip $20.
No, no, no.
I heard what you said.
Chat, we just hit gold.
She didn't even know what we're looking at right now.
I wish you could see it, Doki.
I wish you could see all the stuff I'm seeing right now in
this hole.
It's okay.
I have an idea.
Maybe if you duo queued with me, you would have been able to
see it.
But you're just gonna solo queue.
That's right.
I'll be making a video about this.
Not until I make it first.
I am in a cave now.
Oh.
Okay, chat.
Wait, are you actually in a cave?
Wouldn't you like to know?
Okay, then I won't tell you.
I won't tell you what I've just found.
Well, too bad.
I really wanted to show you this thing I found, but too bad.
I guess you'll never know.
You'll never know this cool thing I found.
Oh, guess who was back at home?
Maybe I'll see it under the earth.
I've been above ground before.
I've seen all there.
I'm gonna eat my dinner right now while you suffer in that
cave.
I'm gonna get water and then eat my dinner while you're
stuck in that cave.
Yeah, sure you are.
At least I get to see the sunlight.
I'm gonna be right back.
I'm gonna get water.
Well, let's see.
Let's see how you do without iron, huh?
Because I hit the mother load.
Wouldn't you like to know weather, girl?
That's like my favorite fucking meme, dude.
Wouldn't you like to know, weather boy?
What do they teach in these kids?
Dude, wait, okay, glowing, glowing moss or mushrooms or
something?
And this time it's glowing gold.
It kind of reminds me of your beautiful hair, Doki, if only
you could have seen it.
Whoa.
A boom shroom.
Maybe it won't.
mind that actually actually maybe that's not worth
celebrating yeah i'm gonna say it's exploding and i'm not
gonna conduct any research welcome back oh my gosh are you
still in that cave oh yeah i made a fresh discovery wait
what the hell where did these mice come from whoa whoa whoa
oh it would be such a shame if you died in the cave and you
had no one to no one to mourn for your death and you just be
a forgotten forgotten raccoon sounds like you miss me huh
nope you want to mourn no if I pass away you would feel I
will celebrate your death oh my god I will find your death
marker and dance on it whoa that's sucking right that's
going in the video I knew my hatred for raccoons was
justified this was a setup this was a setup you're all you
know what they said not all raccoons all raccoons are just
like that this was just to set up just like you it's like
she sees red when she sees her she just she couldn't help
lock me in a hole she you know i thought you were different
i thought you were an exception but i was birds of prey i
see how it is huh i'm glad i sent you that video
Oh my god.
That's right, you raccoon.
That's right.
I'm gonna queue up.
Don't you play Rocket now, huh?
No.
You think I haven't watched your streams before, huh?
Yeah, I've seen you on Rocket.
I thought you were the exception.
Rocket was the exception now.
Maybe you just changed your mind, huh?
Maybe you were the one.
Your best friend, Rocket Raccoon?
Yep.
I can be like him.
You want me to be no hey dokey What about now by by more
appealing to No That's right Rocket would have res me what
have you done?
What have you done for me?
I didn't even I would have when have I ever killed you?
No, no, when have you ever what have I ever killed if
anything and you killed me I said I was gonna come back for
you and did i come back i did did you because i didn't even
get to see you i came back for you and all i got was death
oh my god is this the way out oh chat the sky there's no way
you dug up from here you dug up and actually got out
persevered bitch hell yeah you are so lucky oh my god GDP
you're so oh my god I have a feeling we're gonna have to
move houses huh I think I'm taking my bed and I'm gonna move
it what bed what bed where's my bed I don't see it on the
map anymore she took everything from me what you took 50% of
my items I took what's right what rightfully belonged to
you motherfucker i wish pvp was on i would cast the most
heinous spell on your location right now i would smite you
from the heavens you know what i'm gonna find what heavens i
know you're not going up there i have done nothing i didn't
i didn't kill you that was an innocent fall okay i remember
your my the final words i heard when i fell to my death was
you die who said that i was trying to warn you because there
was a large fall and i did not have the means you told me to
dig down oh yeah and then you you didn't feel the need to to
warn me you know when chat i'm not the divorced dad doki is
the divorced dad i'm the sexy mom oh my god Maybe like when
you were younger, I guess.
She took my fucking balls, you guys.
Damn it.
You're past your prime raccoon.
What?
That's why I'm thriving.
How many deaths are you at, huh?
Oh, yeah.
How many times have I protected you?
Now you have no bodyguard.
Uh-oh.
Watch out bodyguard.
I just upgraded.
And you look like just enough XP.
Yeah.
you're so lucky pvp is turned off oh my god i don't think
we'd play the game it would just be i'm zeroing in on your
position right now no it's gonna be like the monte python
mean i'm just gonna see you over the horizon you're quite
far i think i have time you're so lucky i'm in my like
fucking fight right now where are you I see you I see you
the essence of the way done distance but you've never gotten
one of those before oh I do I have in my pocket right now I
see you yeah what are you gonna do hit me kiss me I just
want to see how it feels yeah let's go to the gym real quick
while we rode our like exercise bikes next to each other how
did it feel sweating on the yeah sharing our water bottles
oh yeah i see you i'm gonna get in the shower i'm so sweaty
after digging in that hole oh you wanna you wanna hurt me so
bad I hope we can counter a boss.
Oh, what is that guy?
Oh, that guy looks like the guy who protects the thing in
Terraria.
Oh my god, never mind.
Dude, don't fuck with that guy, actually.
Oh my god.
I'm safe, I think.
Why are there void bad guys?
That's new.
Because they're protecting the portal.
There's no portal.
Yes, there is.
What the fuck?
I'm literally in the portal right now.
What?
Yeah, jokes on you.
You missed out on some sick-ass portal action.
Are you in heaven?
Yeah.
Because they accepted me there, unlike some other people.
He looks so fucking sad.
These guys look like they're about to cry.
Oh, hey, look at that.
I'm in heaven.
How did you enjoy your heaven experience?
Wow, I guess they accepted me and not you.
I guess you were turned away from the gates.
I'm with the villagers, actually.
I'm with my people.
I'm doubting it.
What did I not?
Oh, 28 memories?
Eggs.
holy shit I have a lot of shit right now chat what is worth
to spend your items on like the essence I don't I feel like
isn't it RNG like the stuff you can trade just like
minecraft oh you can morph into atoms is it how do you morph
into atoms stocks at six oh yeah is food worth to spend oh
Guess we'll find out how worth that is.
I am injured, so.
Oh, shit.
What's wrong?
Nothing.
I was just...
I just tripped, you know?
Nothing bad's happening to me.
Sounds like you tripped quite far.
Yeah, no, no, I just tripped, you know?
I just did, like, a double trip, you know?
Like, you know, you tripped once, and then you tripped
again.
we could go check that out i don't know if i trust you
around small cavernous locations no don't worry it'll be
fine i'm gonna put this garbage out of my inventory holy
these guys are so tanky
what guys nothing are you fighting the beholders all right
walk come here come here come here oh wait did you kill him
yeah i did this is over here there's one over there i lured
him into the cave wait really yeah this is a big cave are
you sure you're ready to use your arms to cover this whole
block i'm gonna go kill i'm gonna go lure this guy come to
the cave with me oh my god wait up the holders here all
right you got him i don't think you're hitting him you are
missing every shot i was not let's Look at that one.
You were missing.
Yeah, he doesn't care.
I did this CSGO, like, crosshair thing.
He does not care what's going on.
He doesn't.
I'm gonna kill this guy, because he doesn't care about me.
He's literally running away.
I halted?
Oh, wait, I can- I can- Oh my god, I killed him!
Holy shit!
Wait, did you actually?
Yeah.
Oh.
You need a void.
You.
Little thief.
You phantom thief.
Oh, someone should have been faster.
You're too slow.
One raccoon who's swiping quicker.
I guess you're just a little too slow.
Can I pick up the old arrow?
Sort of.
I'm not coming to...
Let's go explore the cave.
I mean, that's like the one thing we haven't done yet.
Okay.
What's that?
That's my reaction to that information.
Wait, come on, Snuffy.
We haven't gotten a chance to go to the cave yet, Snuffy.
Oh, my God.
I wonder what is to see.
Wait, where is that hole?
It was like this way, right?
Yeah.
I think it's...
Oh, it's here.
Alright.
I need to make a torch.
Okay, what do I have?
Chad, what is worthless moss?
I feel like I have to, like, I'm going to get rid of this.
I mean, we can get the moss from these grasses.
Can you duo hand?
Oh my god, wait.
Yeah, yeah.
It's on your left side.
Okay, cool.
Oh, there's mossy stones here.
I did see something called boom.
mushrooms so you see yellow glowing mushrooms i'm just gonna
say that could be dangerous an astute observation there's
spider webs here i didn't see spider webs
oh my god there's so many over here oh there's like gotta be
like a spider spawner yeah it's the boom shroom where's the
boom shroom oh wait look oh look at the bright side what is
that ew oh oh it's oh people yeah can i you there's a lot of
them i can't even eat what is that a pile of scars is it
just more scars ew where are the spiders yeah yeah if
there's they didn't program them it's a work in progress I
don't know if it's iron.
I'm gonna grab the iron real quick.
Did we go in a circle?
I don't think so.
Could we make a skull throne?
Oh my god, I want to make a skull throne.
What?
Yeah, look at...
There's a lot of skulls.
Wait, what the fuck is that?
Right?
Oh my god.
Goblin miner.
Wait, what is this?
Is this a sledgehammer?
Oh!
Whoa.
Oh, man, I'm calming.
Oh, my God.
No PvP.
You can just launch me to my death.
Oh, my God.
Wait, wait, wait.
What is this?
It's white.
God damn it.
No.
I got to take a beating.
Oh, I think it's iron.
What is the yellow stuff?
Oh, that was copper this whole time.
Oh, my God.
I was playing Minecraft.
Daddy's angry.
Wait, watch out, Daddy.
There's some bad guys behind you.
Don't worry, Daddy's got this.
Oh, my God.
I will need you to light the way, though.
I can only...
Okay, okay, yeah.
There's nothing up here.
Actually, I can swap.
You can launch me that far?
Oh, you're right.
Do you need help?
My kid is...
Dude, there's more rats than there's like a spider.
I swear, I've never seen zero spider.
Wait, maybe down here?
Come down here.
Okay.
Oh, it's going deep.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Find it.
Wait, what's that?
Are you just the boom mushrooms?
Oh.
Yeah.
Oh, this is going deep.
Yeah, this is a...
What is Doki's slapshot?
What does that mean?
Her slapshot?
What?
My what?
We have not seen a single spot, yet there's so much webs.
Wait, what's this?
Blue cave moss.
This is a deep-ass tunnel, I will say.
Like, cave.
Did you run through here already?
Yeah, I ran.
I just zoomed through.
I was hoping to find something new, but...
Oh, there's a lot of ore here, though.
Oh, there's emerald.
Is that emerald?
Orium ore?
What the fuck is that?
Yeah.
Uranium.
Yeah, is that fucking uranium, dude?
Oh, my God.
Can we make it?
Yeah, I was gonna say everyone make a fucking bomb.
Let's take it to heaven
Let's end this you and me and my nuclear bomb Let's see your
what is your infinite walls?
Oh my god, we still keep going down.
It still goes down.
Well, I'll wait for you Do you have a favorite Minecraft
song?
I really like the I might dig straight down one.
Which one?
It's like, chat, what song is that based off of?
It's just like...
I might dig straight down.
Oh, I thought you were thinking about, like...
What is it?
The digging song?
How did that go?
Remember the digging song?
Straight down.
Hold on.
That was a classic.
Oh, yeah, here it is.
Wait, do you have, do you have like...
Are you allowed to...
Can you listen to songs?
Not, I can listen to it, but then my chat won't hear it.
Oh, really?
Yeah.
I don't know if this is copywritten because it's like a
Minecraft song though.
Right?
So it works.
On fourth and I'm digging a hole.
Dig, dig, dig.
What?
Do you not have any like Minecraft cover songs you like?
I like the creeper one.
I only have the Spotify link for this one, but it's my
favorite.
Wait, which one?
Let me see.
I'm playing it for my chat.
or link it Oh Oh my god, it played I Forgot discord is
linked to my oh, I'm sorry.
Whoa, my child was like whoa I'm sorry too dang it's a
little loud
I forgot my discord is linked to my gaming stuff God, I'm
sorry.
I think I lost you.
Oh, wait.
Now you're over here.
I'm like down.
You see my torch?
No.
I went straight down.
You went straight down.
I might be lower than you.
No, I'm pretty sure you're above me.
Yeah, I know.
You're definitely above me.
No way.
There's nowhere to go down.
I'm such a noob.
Are you going down or up right now?
I'm going left and right.
There's no down or down.
All right.
You're going further away.
Literally, you're further away from me.
These guys kind of look like you, chat.
They look like my curators.
These little grubs.
Yeah, no, you're above me.
You're above because I went down and you got further away.
I found uranium.
What the hell?
Green crystal.
starts where the fuck are you oh oh that's freaky i
did it all for diamonds i did all this morning yeah oh
you're so you're so ahead what you're like down you did not
go down i went down no i went I might dig straight down.
Wait, what is that?
Doki, wait, come back to me.
I found something critical.
Wait, I found some things, Doki.
I found some things.
I think I'm...
Doki, I found two separate things of interest.
I found some things, too.
What did you find?
Are you by the fortress or by the...
Oh, I'm by the great...
Oh, I do not like this place.
The great?
What?
Where are you?
I found a spider's nest.
Wait, what?
Where are you?
I do not like that.
Up or down?
You gotta be up, dude.
No, no, no, no.
You're gonna...
Oh, you're 33 meters away from me.
That could be, like, distance.
I found the spider.
I found this.
must be a spotter oh my god wait it can poison really oh
wait wait wait no you died wait no now i have no idea where
you went don't care now i'm stuck that in the hell by myself
well you're still here no how i just i did not spot in my
bed oh
cave spider dude it just said you died to a regular cave
spider well i have lost my oh I'm a thorium we're still here
though dude I'm stuck in the caves again by myself and you
don't even get to see this like dwarf fortress that I found
you found a dwarf fortress and so sort of like glowing lava
hole how the fuck were you gonna find oh my god how do you
get that privilege I don't I was trying to find you whoa oh
my god there's some sort of goblin in here oh it's the
mining At least I kept my hammer, though.
Ooh, there's a cow here.
Smash!
That's fucking right.
What the fuck is that?
This guy's throwing fucking bombs.
Wait, are these bad?
Oh, I can ult.
Boom!
Oh, and I kill the crab with me.
Alright, I'm heading back.
You're killing crabs, and I'm down here in the mines.
I still don't know how to respawn in the bed.
I slept in the bed.
It didn't let me respawn.
I don't understand.
I kept my creepy skull heads, at least.
That's a plus.
I don't know.
I don't know how to respawn.
Maybe it's like a server problem.
There's a bear.
Holy crap, an iron helmet.
Whoa, upgrade.
It looks like I'm really in business now.
Okay, Bear is gone.
Bear is gone.
I am safe now.
I still have to claim your bed.
I did claim my bed.
I slept on it too.
I don't remember seeing you claim your dang bed.
I literally slept in front of you.
What do you mean?
We looked each other in the eye when we went to bed.
I was enraptured by my own feet.
I'll be real.
I tell put some dirty souls on this girl oh if you're if
you're too far from your bed it'll send you the spawn are
you oh I know it does that so apparently yeah you're too far
and you don't respawn all
right well I'm having the time in my life if you were
wondering this is great this is like super comfortable I bet
you are I bet you are chat look Look how many amazing,
awesome green crystals there are.
What does this even do?
Green crystal shard.
Oh, I found an emerald.
Wait, what?
What is that?
What the fuck are you finding?
Oh my God, there's like a bad guy and he's like glowing red.
What the fuck?
What the fuck are you finding right now?
Damn.
All right, where did I die?
Oh my god, I'd take a look.
Somebody said if the space for the bed is invalid, you might
not spawn there either.
It's okay, I have an idea.
How many arrows I got?
I do not remember where the hole is, but I have an idea.
I'm coming back.
Zero arrows?
But I just docked one.
Oh no.
oh oh no apparently you don't actually fire though how do
you craft arrows chat how are you having like the easiest
time of your life in that cave and i got bit by a cave
spider maybe you should have epaled me i would i'm giving
you one star that's not how you talk to a paying customer I
have plenty of people waiting for my keys I'm sorry yeah oh
yeah how come I got my service so fast after I placed the
request over the first or the second one you are you are you
are so desperate when I put that order in oh yeah ready to
play ready to ready to loot off my e-girls they pay for
everything for me I'm almost back did that have to be
present for this he makes stick have you looted the dwarf
fortress yet or no oh my god there's another one there's
only like one chest yeah it was kind of small just one
there's other stuff oh god oh god I'm trying to find that
cave we're the fuck was that cave.
I don't care about me.
Can't you see, I'm like in the cave.
You just dig straight down and you see me.
Nothing bad will happen to you.
Yeah.
Nothing bad will happen if you dig straight down.
I mean nothing bad happened to you, but something bad
happened for me for sure.
I'm trying to find that forest, like the little critter
fort.
Oh, there it is.
Okay, I know where it is.
I know where the hole is.
I found the hole.
A flute?
Wait, I can make a digital.
Diggery do?
Wait.
Oh my god.
That's one of the mods.
That's one of the mods I added.
Wait, really?
Wait, wait.
Not the flute part, but like.
The didgeridoo?
Make the didgeridoo.
There's a very fun mod that I added for it.
Yes.
Thank you for your enrichment, Doki.
I just didn't realize it would take us this long to find a
fucking instrument.
I'm just crafting it.
Wait, you can craft it?
you're fucking stupid fucking rat there you go why is there
so many rats in the song cave songs are these play your did
you do and I'll find you I will find you my oh my god he
like this fucking stupid ass but oh my god I'm so oh my god
no no No, the spider is back!
The spider is back to kill me!
Are you hearing my jams?
I just see the death notification and I'm just chilling
here, jamming out.
Get out of the fucking cave.
You gotta stop running into these spiders.
I don't think they like you.
Maybe you're beefing with the spiders, not reckoning.
20 spotters and you out there jamming to your didgerie do I
gotta kill this glowing red guy though.
He's cool.
No, oh my hammer's still here.
I found my hammer's still here
No, he's oh just his bat.
He's having she's having like the easiest playthrough of her
life and I just went through Okay, it's called having skill.
Oh, yeah.
Yeah.
How many spotters have you had?
How many?
many spiders have you encountered you raccoon because i'm
skillful at avoiding threats oh yeah yeah it's called brains
over bronze i hope you get bit by a blue look it's like
rainbow over here there's a i hope you get bit by a spider a
blue one oh don't you there's so many colors
this is wonderful oh man oh man there's some sort of like i
don't like blocking fast dude oh i hope i find some sort of
magic wand that's it that's it i'll wait for you at home
whoa you're literally turning this car around yeah that's it
you go gather i'm going back skeleton fighter whoa where the
fuck is home there it is what is that that looks like the
the guy from freaking man I wish I know what that looked
like he looks just like in crash bandicoot you would play
crash bandicoot yeah yeah the which one though he's in the
first game it's the map yeah he's in all games what the fuck
you mean yeah he's like from the first one though all right
let's see what can I make oh man what can I make I need any
tree log and any stone Okay, well, I wish I have any of
those things Okay Tree log and stone I gotta go cut some
trees now
Okay, that Yeah, see that bunny hop, guys Dude, I hope I get
this guy's flaming sword Would that be like, wouldn't Doki
just, like, love that
It's okay, guys a new job now this is my new job in life i
am so fulfilled i am i'm i'm so fulfilled right now chat oh
my god this guy is grieving me i don't have enough errors to
kill him he wants to be so tanky and like high level dude
that's crazy there's a tiny little mice wait she's gone oh
oh you think you can hide from me oh you think you can hide
little micey mice i don't need you snuffy this guy oh my god
he's kind of a pussy what you hear oh yeah oh you're coping
that's what this is no no no i just saw i literally showed
up behind you you didn't notice me you're using admin
commands yeah i teleported behind you i do own the server i
would believe that yeah dude chat how cooked am i this guy's
not dying he's wearing like super elite level armor yeah but
you kill him you would get super elite armor oh there's
chickens here that's all you have to be excited about where
you are is chickens man what is smash what is that dude
there's all sorts of baddies over here man you're missing
out oh it's okay i saw some chickens.
Yeah, but did you see the sick-ass chickens?
I didn't think so.
That's right.
You missed out.
Oh, look at that sheep.
Oh, you missed out on some sheep.
Whoa!
Look at that sick-ass sheep here.
Suddenly, you are the farming girl, and I am the killing
girl.
No, I'm just, you know, I'm retired.
You know, like, the farm.
You know, it's when Thanos retired, and he started a farm.
that's just me what the fuck is that this guy is actually
unkillable i shot him like a million times and i've just
been like harping on him with my thing and he hasn't died
what is it i found lava but for oh wait make a bet don't
worry guys i have a bed that i found right here
you can turn on health fires is that cheating oh yeah
there's enemy health bars that you turn on oh maybe i should
turn that on maybe that'll show me how believable this is
all right where's enemy health fires
how do i get up here crystalline deaths what the is this
island i found an island oh you're missing out Oh, show
entity hellfires.
Okay, wait.
What?
Oh, my God.
Oh, wait.
No, that's that thing.
What?
He healed.
Oh, my God.
He healed?
Oh, is that why it took forever?
Wait, he's not healing now.
I don't understand.
Oh, he heals after some time.
I gotta go.
Oh, fuck you.
Stop it.
Hold on.
I gotta go back and plan my approach.
You're missing out right now.
I'm in, like, a really crazy...
A really crazy area.
Man, I wish if only you could see this.
Whoa.
This is definitely the most crazy thing you could see.
No, no, no, no.
This is the craziest thing.
If only you could see this right now.
Oh, but you can't.
You wouldn't sound like a snake oil salesman if that was
you.
You can't, you can't because you're still trapped in a cave.
chat I know right this place is trapped in a cave by choice
I don't know chat this place is fucking crazy right now what
you need is a spear oh true chat I don't know how to make a
spear man mad if only she could see this right now oh but
she can oh I'm gonna craft this furnace I'm gonna live down
here dokey is that okay you guys gonna live where the fuck
are there's some cool shit down here maybe if you lived you
would have been able to be in this grind oh my god if oh
what the fuck is that a skeleton horse i've seen those in
minecrafted come on oh no but you haven't seen this skeleton
horse oh i'm in the charred woodlands right now oh you're
missing out this shit this place is crazy yeah yeah you can
ride the skeleton horse too Oh, yeah, really?
Are you going to take this into the cave with you?
Oh, my God.
Oh, there's hellhounds.
Hey, this place is for you.
Wait, really?
Oh, I think I've seen one of the...
Wait, no.
No, I have, like, lava lizards.
What is a hellhound?
I die if I...
Yeah, I will die.
I need logs, chat.
Wait, there's actually logs down here.
Wait, this place is everything.
Cool.
Are you just going to live down there?
Why, did you miss me?
No, I just want to know before, like, you know, before I,
like, burn all your items.
Oh, my God!
You're gonna burn the home we had!
You already, like, took a gun from me, didn't you?
I want to know you're living there before I burn the house
down.
Yeah.
Is that the Grim Reaper?
Holy shit!
Wait, the Grim Reaper is here!
What?
Okay, maybe I'm a little jealous now.
Yeah, that's right.
I'm literally in hell right now.
No surprise there, but like, jealous.
I got there first.
I'm literally in hell right now.
Yeah, you jealous?
I got there first before you.
Hmm.
How did you get into hell?
Oh, I climbed the...
What was your process like?
I climbed a mountain.
and then i was there dang it's on top of a mountain maybe
it's some sort of like viking hell yeah it's viking hell
jealous and people that's why i'll see what this giant evil
flaming skeleton warrior drops then i'll tell you it's
because like you know they were running out of space at uh
um in the you know bottom hell so you gotta make room so
they like
hell you know yeah am i gonna get sent to bottom hell when i
die bottom hell or upper hell upper hell is like for the you
know for people who have the money you know yeah yeah yeah
for the ceos okay dumb question how do i get sticks that's
what you mean that's anybody how do we get a stick can i
turn log into stick somehow fuck am i gonna from the surface
there's gotta be a way oh man if only you could be on the
surface right now oh I don't need it I don't need those fuck
is that god damn it oh that's oh my okay okay um the undead
cow is surprisingly very strong damn did you no I am very
alive we can have like contraptions in this game what the
hell oh it's like redstone I don't know what is this gear oh
my god there's a piano oh so it's like steampunk yeah I
think steampunky yeah trying to get to the other side of
this island also this fucking hell area has nothing except
for a horse like i visited upper hell not like i was a
stupid horse
that's it maybe if you come down to bottom hell with me
you'll find something else worth your time like a friend she
just snickered at me oh wait where is this place was that
lion what the shit i'm about to build an armor bro there's a
saber tube tiger here okay bro what the fuck are dinosaurs
real
whoa oh my god dinosaurs are real
craft any of this shit what the hell i'm at the savannah now
yeah i'm not coming home damn i'm too far gone we're we're
separated yeah the paper don't worry the papers are gonna
come by in the
morning no um i would like 50 of everything they told me the
cool guy approach would have worked happened I lost my duo
cute honestly the worst e-pal I've ever had what one out of
five stars oh this was on my smurf account actually is that
a cow oh that's my workbench that's right in fact I'm gonna
contact I'm gonna contact the website and get the matter
refund I
hope you enjoy your card getting declined from being on a
suspicious website We'll see how that goes for you when you
have to make your case I'm gonna do a charge back That's
fucking right I'm gonna file a charge back now Well I'm
gonna take you to court
Not before filing papers first You're slandering my service
For slander I run a good business here Miss Doki bird What
kind of business, huh?
The e-girl, I have the e-girl minds.
Oh, and?
I'm judging by your average reviews.
It hasn't been such a great business.
It's hard to start up a business.
Well, he's running away.
You're really going to end the life of a small business?
Oh, my God.
You didn't even think about it.
That's right.
I'm going to make my call-out video first before you can get
anything out.
Fuck.
Then I'll make my call-out video.
on my voice critical channel this stokey bird situation is
crazy i need to like figure out a fucking encase my horse
surely i can craft a better weapon and then i'm gonna put
that guy to rest dude whoa can
i like place blocks while i'm all right i'm gonna put you up
here see oh wow oh my god my horse almost killed me
fuck i can't burn this oak branch why not we need a redeem
where we eat points into the abyss that's true oh let's hope
none of these things more redeems um dude i'm running out of
options there's no coal in the mines oh it's crazy you're up
here enjoying the high life
man uh-huh it sucks to be you i'm having a great time in my
new home with all my new friends okay name one friend um
skelly the skeleton horse that sounds like a bad guy um oh
just because he's a skeleton he's a bad guy i would be your
friend yeah yeah are you are you judging are you judging my
friend right now by his appearance i just feel like he
doesn't have i feel like someone who judged people by their
appearance are not a good is not a good person what no i'm
not judging yeah you don't even i'm just yeah i'm looking
out for you man how so you weren't looking out for me when
that spider bit me where were you when the spider bit me huh
you didn't even suck the poison out you didn't even suck the
poison out what kind of friend does that you ain't no bro i
would have done it i would have done it oh yeah i got bit
three times escape from you like a slide box i got the three
times and i don't see no sucking oh my god we'll just get
down here so i can suck it already dude i'm gonna i'm going
like freaking what do they call it like stir crazy i don't
know what you can just dismantle in this cave so i can get
enough wood to make freaking copper bars i just want to kill
this guy that's all they want to do.
I don't even know where I went.
Oh my god, this is a giant-ass mine.
Wait, are you coming back for me?
Fuck no.
I'm fucking God.
Look at the map and look where I am.
Look where I fucking am.
Did he really think?
Holy crap.
What did you do?
Get a boat?
What the hell?
You're so far oh my god that's fine that's cool let's put a
torch oh there we go yeah you come to me i'm not coming back
hmm wait how many oh my god i caught myself on fire wait
duck and roll duck and roll oh that's crazy that's a
liability put that out put that out you know i found a new
mine i don't need you i have a Another mine that I found.
Wait, chat, what is the most busted weapon?
Is it the daggers, really?
Holy shit, what?
There was, like, a giant trap here.
Oh, man.
You're missing out right now.
You keep saying that.
How much am I really missing out on, huh?
You're missing.
Oh, my God.
Yeah, you're missing out a lot.
Oh, shit.
It sounds like you're stressed.
No.
I just tripped.
You know, those moments when you just trip?
Like, those silly moments.
No, I never trip.
I never...
I never fuck up.
I never miss.
I'm always on my mark.
What about you?
Yeah, that never happens to me either.
That's why we're separated.
yeah I kind of like these bats they make a good noise they
fill me with less loneliness oh you're going stir crazy they
sound like little farts what you would know if you were down
here yeah it's too bad too bad I mean you're missing out all
these new friends i made the only friend i ever wanted i
don't need them oh how come you didn't save my life huh how
come you just let me die i'm gonna kill that i'm gonna kill
that spider would have done when you didn't kill him huh how
did you help me
get Oh Fuck I needed those logs shit.
Give me those back.
No, it's too late.
They're gone.
Okay, I'm okay I'm okay.
I'm so healthy
I'm so healthy smile.
I'm so healthy.
Oh man.
Oh, what the fuck is this diamond?
Oh You missed out on some diamonds.
Yep chat open her stream right now tell me if she's looking
at like swamp water okay be real you missed out on some
fucking diamonds too bad too bad only look at that my mind
was better than your mind in the end what i haven't even
i've been i've been building up my mind i've been building
up my evil fortress actually so wrong again yeah spend all
that time in your stupid mind didn't even a diamond i'm
still in the mine huh yeah wait still in the mines still
haven't found the diamonds though what's the point i have my
oboe stupid oboe holy shit a hundred sand what the fuck am i
gonna do with all that sand wood down here man there's gotta
be free wood somewhere
what you missed out look at that i gotta die no look at that
you couldn't get that in your fucking mind look at that
there's no more wood i gotta fucking die chad what did you
get um yeah i'm gonna kill this guy or lose everything Do
these boxes ever have...
Oh, they do have things in them.
Man, if only...
I wouldn't know about that.
That was awesome.
That was actually really epic that you said that.
Wait, are these gonna explode?
Where the fuck are you doing?
I'm playing pinata.
What the fuck?
Wait, can I climb this rope?
That was an amazing thing at that.
I'm okay.
I'm gonna kill this guy.
Steven, I feel like we're gonna have to kill this guy.
Holy shit, this mine shaft is like so...
So much stuff going on here.
I found a dog.
I found diamonds.
Oh, I cannot cook meat in the stove.
I found him...
I found a cat now too.
Oh my god, this mine shaft has everything.
Except a companion by your side, huh?
No, I have a dog.
He's not a real fan like I am.
He's not a T3 sub with me.
I don't know.
He's been here for me since the beginning.
I was literally there.
I remember that.
When the fuck did that happen?
Okay, chat.
Wait, I'm about to...
Oh, crap.
someone's broken this is it this is the end for me I'm
afraid oh okay I'm so healthy my dog broke my fall your dog
broke your fall what what yeah I landed directly on the dog
and then I'll expire the dragons and shit yeah if only you
that too bad you didn't
he's alive too it's like the perk it's like the the
companion perk you don't know how that feels I walk my path
alone chat says you fell from a high place and you have 10
health and no dog by your side chat's lying to you
who would you believe um one guy or dokey the bird yeah
who's more trustworthy at this point who is more like
trustworthy here huh this is like an even match me in this
what the hell damn it okay never mind it's less than even
though i need raw meat no you have to oh you can't step off
a-hole you expect me right right behind you dude your kda is
looking like oh and five right now um it was like five and
five get your facts right
what the is going on here
first try exactly i got it says i got it says wait what died
over there something else died over there oh my god what is
that Oh, what happened?
Nothing, nothing at all.
Oh, it'd be a shame if something happened to you.
What a shame.
Oh my god.
Nope, nope, I'm good.
How's that skeleton mage, though?
Oh, died in first try.
Nothing to worry about.
Did it first hit, no death run.
Yeah.
didn't die once dude what the hell i got slurped i can't i
gotta get out of here this place is terrifying on like for
real what is who is groaning hello what is that what's wrong
with this guy
what's going on i don't know it's just some guy he's oh that
hurts there's evil there's evil
can i not parkour if i've got oh god i don't like those
frogs chat i really don't that's really scary well do you
have horns everything's fine nope yep maybe i don't know i
didn't look at it
oh my god what's that a door girl to what oh my god what was
that to what oh no oh no oh man much stuff around me now oh
my god get out of here we gotta go we gotta go we gotta
fucking go holy shit oh my god oh my god oh no no no no no
no no excuse me i'll be ashamed of something happened to you
right about now i'm so fucking scared dokey everything is
dangerous why did i put that on the floor put my raw meat on
the floor oh my god oh you make copper copper pickaxes oh my
god that's what that's what wars are for guys i finally
figure out what the ores are for
get the hell out of here chat we're making it out we're
making it out alive oh
oh my god i really thought that was gonna explode
You're awfully quiet, Doki.
You find something awesome?
Yeah.
Yeah, I found my...
Some might say I found the matrix.
What?
What does that mean?
I've only watched the Matrix one time I was like five.
She took the blue pill or the red pill.
I guess.
You'll never know.
The wild ride I just went on.
Because you'll never have the privilege.
I've got so much cool things in my inventory.
I don't know what to sub anytime I find something cool now.
Because I've got too much cool stuff.
Is this a problem you're also facing?
Yeah.
Yep.
I have so much cool stuff that like you can't even imagine
the things I found
what the fuck oh I don't have a chest I just want to find
like an exit
my new home what the fuck is this I love how anytime I tap
into my although it's actually still just like playing oh
okay I'm still now
man if you see my house right now you're gonna be so jealous
yeah what if I show up right now to your house huh?
I don't even think you'll make it
I'm gonna fight tooth and nail to get there yeah I don't
even think you'll know how to find it It's so, it's like a
gated community.
Damn.
I'm on my way to LA.
Here I come.
Where the fuck are like, oh there it is.
Where the fuck are like the stones around here?
Are there no stones in the desert?
Is it just all sand?
Yeah, it's pretty exclusive.
I don't even know if you can, if it'll let you in.
Knowing your kind.
Yeah, you know.
I heard like, you know.
I'm coming.
You are a Stokey Bird.
I'm on my way right now.
Trash Raccoon, right?
Here I come.
I don't know if they let trash in here.
Recycling was yesterday.
You ran out of time.
I don't know what that means.
I was like, to me, I was like, what the fuck is...
It's like, in my head, it sounded really cool.
Recycle was yesterday, and you didn't take your bin out.
You want to...
I'll give you a round two.
A moss horn?
You want to try again.
I'm coming.
I hope there's room for two.
Oh.
all right i'm gonna put more blocks down make sure rainbow
trout oh my gosh wow this fish is huge how fucked do i what
is that there must be an easier way to farm rocks right
like any stone like obviously cobblestone doesn't count
right i'm running around on the the sand and the cobblestone
my bare square feet feels great did
you make a boat or something nope that's what i'm saying i
don't know you can make it to me wait what what the fuck oh
my god what do you mean muting this oh i'm okay
really whoa this place is so beautiful wow very scenic onto
your house stokey my way down there and taking a nice
beautiful path on these yeah colorful forests yeah the view
is pretty nice too bad you don't get to win so far too bad
you don't get to see it you are literally like a thousand
meters away yep yep yep i'm enjoying life right now my new
beautiful home right oh I hope I get to see it right oh okay
yeah it's like a gated community of sorts you keep saying
that are you in some sort of fortress yeah it's like yeah
it's like a little town it's a little college town you know
is this hell is this the hell is this the mountainous hell
you were no i have like a little college town that um
college town yeah yeah it only but you know you have to do
applications uh to even be like um eligible to live here
okay can i oh i don't know you gotta file an application
like openings every couple of years you know whenever you
know years yeah because when you live here you live here
forever type deal because it's like a college town it's like
forever oh it's your fucking grave this is what people do
when they get funeral graves dude no no it's like it's like
your forever home you know so is your grave it's like your
forever home so like whenever applications open you know
like you know the the oldest like resident there died so the
oldest resident oh oh god help why he hate me what is that a
gecko jellyfish he hate me whoa oh
understand i thought i was through my toes i thought we cool
yeah yeah i'm gonna gatekeep here i'm gonna gatekeep she
doesn't deserve this beautiful town i'm coming i'm coming
don't gatekeep just just put me in your leases a pet oh they
don't accept pets unfortunately no yeah what about your dog
oh um i they gave me an exception because i was such a good
neighbor they're like you know what you were such a good
neighbor um that we decided you can bring your pet to this
house can i ride this no what is that are you like a guy
that looks like you over here dokey wait what the fuck whoa
this place is cool kind of looks like your turf how did you
get here what do you mean whoa this place looks cool oh my
god whoa is this your place wow yeah like really fancy
welcome to my crib yeah yeah i'll give you a tour there's
camels yeah i'll let you be yeah i'll let you be my plus one
i'll let you be my plus one yeah yeah i'll put on the guest
pass yeah remember right here you go before we go before we
go here put this on um let's see yeah put that on what do
you mean put this on yeah put that on right my inventory is
full that odd oh well i can't let you in unless you put this
on really yeah is this like the It's like, no, it's like
they'll hit you if you don't put it on.
Um...
You gotta get some, you gotta get rid of something.
You know, cause you got, you know, they're like, you know,
it's such a closed-off gated community.
So...
I think I'm gonna, I think I'll play my music for them and
they'll...
What's that?
That's cool over there.
Is this it?
Yeah, yeah.
Yeah, this is where...
This is where I've been living.
Look, I'm going to warn you, though, because you don't have
your...
You don't have your guest pass on.
They might not like that.
It's very, very expensive.
Yeah, I'll just say I'm, like, waiting for the...
Oh, my God, wait.
Yeah.
I don't think they like you.
Oh, wait.
They're afraid of me.
I don't think they like you.
Oh, my God, wait, yeah.
Wait, that's the...
That's the...
That's the RA.
You should talk to her.
All right.
Yeah, that's the RA.
like me.
That's the RA.
I mean, you are my guest so you might have to talk to her
just in case.
You think she'll like your music?
I don't think they liked it.
They ran away from me.
No, no, no.
Come here.
Snuffy.
That's the RA.
Y'all play your music to her.
Go up to her.
Oh, I definitely don't like you.
I think they hate it.
They're like running from me.
Yeah.
Yo, that's gonna like affect my uh, social standing here in
my community.
I'm disturbing the peace.
I don't know if I like it that you're my plus one for this
place.
I might have to kick you out.
Yeah, I mean, I you know, because, like, you know, I like
this community, and I don't really...
You know.
Well, I'll just, there's like a big warehouse over here.
Oh, yeah, that's my garage.
Oh.
Yeah, you're sort of like, disturbing the peace here
disturbing the peace i'll go practice my oboe in your garage
like a like a teen child don't worry it won't harsh your
vibe anymore mama oh my god there's like a saber tooth by my
house is that dangerous no he's pretty he's pretty nice go
up to it play your didgeridoo oh my wait that's your
skeleton horse yeah he's at my house
i kidnapped i kidnapped him from upper hell the desolate
base wait why does it look like you live in here oh it's my
garage you know you know like you know it's my man cave it's
my garage your equipment is all here well what do you use
your house for it's my man cave you know you know when i
like gotta get out of the homes you know gotta get out of
them i can't get out of the homes when the traffic is so bad
out of my house that i just can't leave so i just hang out
my garage yeah hang out my cave garage.
There's a deep pit, bro.
Ah!
You are a dirty little stinker.
Stay away from me.
Oh my god.
Wait, why is this so long?
Ah!
No, no, no!
You!
Okay, you know what?
This is actually nice.
I'll live here.
Nope.
There's nothing you can knock me off of here.
Nice try.
What's up, homie?
I'm gonna...
Make myself comfortable in your crib.
I'm just gonna put my painting of myself up here.
Yep.
My epic anvil.
Me and my anvil, we go way back.
Hopefully you don't mind.
You brought your fucking- Super cool furnace.
You brought your furnace.
Are you fucking squatting now?
You're gonna fucking squat here?
You said this was a nice place.
And I said I would come back for you.
You couldn't squat in my garage?
Nuh-uh.
I moved in.
This isn't part of the game.
You're going to pay rent.
What are you going to pay rent?
Are you going to pay rent?
Are you chart?
Do you own this?
Do you own this property?
Yeah, I own this.
This is literally my garage.
I literally got a mortgage here.
Well, why would you let me live with you?
Because you're not paying rent.
What do you want?
I'm putting all my equipment down.
Wouldn't this please you?
Wait, I've got so much cool stuff.
I was like 50% upfront for rent.
I did 50%.
I need a deposit first.
I need to pause it.
I deposit this.
50%.
I can play anything you want me to play.
Don't worry.
Wait.
What are you into?
What kind of music do you like?
What about all the small things?
All the small things.
It's almost there.
It's like gov.
I can't hit you at all.
all right i would like i would like to request a song if
you're not going to pay a deposit i would like a song
request play me the creeper song um why do they have monkey
island on this what wait wait wait that was a setup that was
a set up okay okay now that you're done kissing me i guess
just finish moving my stuff in here and craft a chest with
all my prized possessions never even paid rent i played you
a song and i have all my goodies that you can have like what
like ores and stuff like what yeah but you have diamond do
you have diamond i thought you found some yeah i told you
okay show me show me your diamond you where's my workbench
there's my regular workbench
Where was it?
Where did it go?
I got it.
Too many workbenches.
Oh, well.
Yeah, you can craft an instrument here if you want.
Wait, where is it?
Oh my god, I just noticed us.
There's a second tab.
Yeah, all of them have multiple tabs.
I was like, man, I can't believe I can only craft like a
campfire and all of that.
Look, you gotta get like wood and shit.
wait we can start a band yeah there's like a backpack which
sounds nice well do I not want but let's start a band wait
play your didgeridoo play my didgeridoo oh there's already a
furnace okay that's cool hold on I'm gonna wait what did you
get what the hell is that oh my god bad apper let me play oh
my god
Are we playing in sync?
Wait.
Oh, my God.
This goes crazy.
We're actually starting a bad.
Wait, wait.
Oh.
Oh, my God.
Wait, wait.
What?
Where's the sand's undertale sound?
Mario underworld.
That's like the sand.
Oh, here we go.
Maybe we're not in sync.
No, we are.
I don't think we are.
We're in sync.
We're totally in sync.
Oh, we're not in sync.
Okay, okay, okay, okay.
Okay, we time it.
That's horrible.
All right, do you see...
It sounds so bad.
Do you see the Imperial March?
Do you see that?
the pure march okay i'll do a countdown three two one go
oh my god i feel like we're really like the band in the yeah
we're like a bar oh my god we did it oh it just ends oh my
god this is beautiful wait wait what are song do we have
Never gonna give you up.
Ready?
I'll say, when I say one, we press it.
Wait, what are we pressing?
Never gonna give you up.
What?
Let's record.
When you say one?
Yeah, when I say one, we press it.
All right?
Three, two, one.
Why did it fucking sound like that at first?
Wait, can I play my instrument all I sleep?
You know the rules I'm so do I No, no, no, no, no, no, no,
no, no It sounds terrible It's because of the fucking
didgeridoo!
How good is it supposed to sound?
Bro, I'm trying to work you What didgeridoo do right now?
You're working with the didgeridooer.
I'm a didgeridgetter-dunner.
I think I can just craft while I do this.
Okay, I need to get, I need to get wood and then I have
everything.
I have a lot of wood here.
Want some of my wood?
Yeah, give me.
Yeah.
I don't actually remember what I need that word.
Oh, a new one.
Wait.
I guess I could just get a look at some copper.
chat how is what the best way to like mine stuff or what
like what do you do for the furnace what did i just throw i
don't know you're just chilling i'm just playing my jab
tree sap you can burn sap oh shit i'm still jamming
that fucking obo sounds so silly Boom, boom, boom.
I didn't think I would ever hear a Degree Do again.
Oh, I'm looking at the backside of your toes right now.
I know.
Hey, don't forget him.
I walked a thousand miles to get here.
And I would walk.
And I would walk by a thousand miles.
There is.
It's over there.
Out there.
Out yonder.
It's just like Death Valley.
There's like nothing but scary dudes around here.
It's a very exclusive club.
year lesser health ocean i like how like if i don't have my
it like plays my guitar again a flamingo what is can i ride
it what a mortal combat song i think there should be a mod
that like lets you ride all the bombs they all look very
like different steeds different mountains i want a world of
warcraft what's us what am i dying to poison oh my god what
is that
oh that's the wasp yeah you gotta be careful about this guy
yeah that guy's poison i'm so done i didn't even i didn't
even i didn't even get to live you're still that oh and i'm
sleep i didn't go to bed oh no my stuff no we were too busy
jamming no oh it's okay i'm back i'm okay if you were
wondering i'm all right i'm so happy i'm so happy to hear
that yay where did you go wow that's great where Where are
you?
Um...
Well, the journey...
Well, let's get a horse, right?
Horse it up.
Just get a horse.
What a shame that you died so far.
That's truly... What did I do?
That's truly...
You're in for your companionship and I was I was left for
dead in the desert I was poisoned like goddamn what's his
name like like Caesar no it's like it's like just playing
hard to get you know it's this don't you know it's the
thrill of the chase the thrill of the chase she'll never let
me have her yeah okay don't drown horse oh the horse can
drown it's like a will they won't they situation it's like
it's like a heated rivalry a heated rivalry my horse and
drowning no i meant i meant the the the situation oh i
thought you were talking about my horse i was like what do
you mean will they won't they drown oh yeah will the horse
they will the horse drown or will the horse they will they
submerge themselves completely under the water and
suffocate.
I don't know.
Yeah, we'll never find out.
Tune in next episode.
Oh, I'll scout here for you.
It'll just take me a while.
My horse has buns for stamina.
I'm like watching you slowly get closer to me on my map.
Oh.
I was like, oh, you're watching?
You're watching me?
Yeah, I'm watching you.
I take your eyes off me, huh?
I'm closing my map now.
Ah, she's shy.
I've decided to close my map.
Don't worry, I'm watching your items despawn in real time.
Oh, this is definitely the hell you were talking about.
Oh, yeah, Upper Hell?
Yeah, that looks like Upper Hell.
I think Madden made it a lot better than...
Maybe I should have gone the peaceful forest way again.
This looks crazy.
How did you get through this?
I made my way top.
I'm going to see if my horse is going to will they won't
they holy crystalline depths i mean you're almost there no
i'm not you're almost there i could just i could see you
right there horsey wait oh oh i'm the horsey won't they oh
can i drown
Oh, so did you get your answer?
Yes, the horses do not breathe for very long.
So now I must traverse hell on foot.
Oh, you know what?
Not so bad.
Will they won't dead?
Now, will Snuffy drown or will Snuffy live?
Let's find out right now on today's episode.
Wait, I'm almost there.
I'm almost there.
yeah can you drown in this game if oh no yes i've i found
out yes you can absolutely drown in this game and how did i
find out well maybe one day you'll get to experience it too
will they won't will they won't they are there dragons in
this game chat i feel like they'll if it doesn't they'll add
it in the future because it's like super early access
apparently right now yeah that's crazy yes there are oh my
god how many wait what can i get from this oh my god whoa
why am i not like researching this right now oh just one but
that sucks i'm gonna only get one fucking plank
let's do okay how do i get creator code also as you guys may
see i got Doki Bird as my name.
Oh, nice.
Because I tweeted it because someone else took Doki Bird.
And then apparently they took Doki Bird from someone else
and then gave it to me.
Yeah.
The admin is like DM me and was like, oh, I can transfer
Doki Bird to you.
And I was like, I don't need theft.
It's not a joke.
That's fucking right, guys.
You got fucking access.
That's right.
I got in.
Tell them to add magic spells now.
I don't even know like.
don't know what name they they gave the other person oh but
they like literally stole like they like literally
transferred their name back to me oh my god oh my god oh my
god oh my god oh my god what's going on you're so close oh
my god oh my god oh my god oh my god nothing nothing at all
don't worry i'll go rescue you
don't worry i'm coming for you snuffy
That's flippin' fantastic.
What's that?
That's me.
Oh, there's like a hell of a...
No, that's me right there.
You not see me?
Are there to see you?
What am I doing?
How many fingers am I holding up?
You're holding, like, zero fingers?
That's a lie.
That's a trick question.
You were holding zero fingers.
I had to shoot my iron helmet, though.
Wait, there's blue gems!
Fuck, these mountains are kind of nice.
There's, like, gems over there.
Yeah, that's what I'm saying.
see i told you i had to climb up this mountain two mountains
actually all right five i found you i guess i leave now
that's cool i'll walk there oh my god there's scorpion
poison is like the worst mechanic oh there's like an oasis
here wait what the fuck is this oh shit my horse kicked me
that's right don't get away from your horse Bye.
I'll meet you at home, base.
Okay, I'll follow your butt.
You hate to see him go, but you love to watch him walk away.
Okay, I'm going to destroy your bed.
I never even put one down.
That's why I'm being flippant all over the place.
I get through here with determination.
dokey there's another one oh goodbye i'm not gonna let him
win this time are you winning
oh my god you actually won oh my god you won i need
something to eat okay i got you i got you i got you give me
a sec wait i'm stuck here give me a sec i got you i got you
what are you doing I got you I got you okay I got you okay
no no no no no no I asked that food here no no no no wait no
no no no no no no
okay I'm for real for real for real I have you for you you
took it no it's literally in front of you it's literally in
front of you I would never do that to you I'm going through
hell when you said hell was in this game it was where you
are yep i'm in upper hill hell though i'm in upper hell
where upper management goes back home again
okay i need a bed
Where do you craft them sleep?
Is that the Among Us song?
Yeah.
It's sus.
I never realized there was a song.
I feel like I already forgot about that.
Like it was ages ago.
Yeah, it feels like 20 years ago when Among Us was...
You know the Among Us TV show still hasn't come out yet.
That's crazy.
I forgot they were gonna make the Among Us TV.
Yeah, that's been in development for so fucking long.
But they got...
We're fine, right?
I'm...
Yeah.
Elijah Wood is like one of the voice actors, too.
Wait, what?
Yeah.
We got the Lord of Rings.
We got the Lord of Rings guy.
Did you hear he's like a DJ, though?
He's a fucking...
Okay, to be fair, he has Lord of Rings money.
He can do whatever the fuck he wants.
I know.
That's pretty awesome, though.
Every time someone fucking watches, does a marathon of Lord
of the Rings, this guy gains like $1,000.
$1,000.
that he doesn't have like lord lord of the ring royalties he
must know there's no fucking way he doesn't get roy they're
had he must have got royalties from that that's not how
movies work yes it is you get paid royalties like a
commercial yeah for like dvd sales and stuff every time
somebody buys like a magic or streaming services i'm pretty
sure because like it depends under contract but i'm pretty
sure because like um because that's what daniel radcliffe
has that's why you could do whatever the he wants because he
has like harry potter royalties i thought he does a bunch of
other acting jobs yeah no but he does indie films yeah but
he does gonna be a different harry potter but he does indie
films because he made so much money from harry potter that
like um he could just do roles that he wants to do type deal
well now he's gonna lose his royalties because they're
changing Harry Potter.
So I feel like it's like, it's like all the scams are now.
Yeah, but I think he was just actors.
I feel like he already invested most of his money.
Yeah, they're probably definitely fine.
Yeah.
It's usually royalty.
Really?
I thought they just get offered like a comically large jack.
I think like nowadays they don't act.
Nowadays they don't do royalties because the royalties are
pretty shit because of streaming.
Because streaming, you don't get much from streaming.
But back then...
like if it plays on tv yeah but like in streaming services
like you normally get like jack now but like back then for
dvds and stuff like and you get a lot and like movie like
you know how back then people like tv when tv was still a
thing they did like rebroadcast of the movies tv was still a
thing oh good tv is dead yeah tv is very dead i don't know
who i guess like the old
people that had the old ones
oh you can't use your guitar to bash the pots are you still
playing never gonna give you up um i'm gonna play the
ancient ones come on shena sanate oh my god i love this song
i'm gonna play i feel like i should be wandering in a dark
tower I was enjoying my sonata.
Oh my face.
Oh my god, that's Undertale, right?
What?
All my fellas?
No?
Oh yeah.
What?
Is that Undertale?
Is that...
What's this?
I made a bed.
There's some song.
I'm like, what the fuck is that?
Oh, there's so many chests in here and stuff.
Oh, yeah, no.
I've, I've, I've sat, like, ate all of that and shit up.
There's stuff in it, though.
No, there's some stuff that, like, I use as, like, my junk
chest.
That's not what that is.
No, no, there's my junk chest.
Oh, my God, I like this song.
Oh my god.
I feel like my elbow is so deep, you can't even hear it.
My lady, shall I serenade you?
I need to, I need to make another instrument.
This one is kind of flopped.
Oh my god, a piano.
So you guys, waiting almost one hour for us was worth it
because one of the mods was this mod.
Yeah, just like how the voice chat mod is really awesome and
working as well.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, the no voice chat.
Dude, your freaking instrument is like stealing the show.
guitar it looks like i'm stroking i see it's so worth it
guys why does it look like this
jerk in the ivories that's that's how i play piano um i am
it's like i'm the lead singer and you're like the backup
okay i sleep here And I watch you.
My lady.
I feel like I'm sleeping.
I'm giving you a bedtime song.
Wait, wait.
I have a perfect bedtime song for you.
Okay, okay.
It's perfect.
And it, like, fits you perfectly.
My lady, is this beautiful?
Are you...
This is just like my mom used to play for me.
are you shocked about beautiful the song was what are you
doing you're just there's no music coming out of your piano
i'm jerking the ivory i'm polishing my piano you're
polishing your piano for the for the next concert right yeah
does my lord appreciate my devotion i'm a lord a song for
you here we go it's um Oh my god.
I don't really...
Wait, this is that one song, DuckTales.
Where's the duck tails?
What song is this again?
Oh my
god!
Oh my god!
Oh my god, they respawn!
Oh my god.
Okay.
Oh my god, oh my god.
Okay, everything is fine.
Everything is fine.
Did you kill the bad guys?
Did you kill them?
Yeah.
Anyway, what song was this again?
This was, um...
This is...
My brain just wants to say the duck tails.
The duck tails.
Duck tails, woohoo.
Oh, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no,
no, there's still a guy here.
Here, I'll give you one more chance.
I got him, I got him.
It's okay.
Is it like Disney?
Wait, let me look at which ones you're playing.
Inspector Gadget.
Oh, wait, no.
Oh,
my God.
I don't actually know what he says.
and inspector got it okay here answer these three riddles
what okay okay duck tails yeah duck tails big duck small
duck duck town you are i'll give you one more one more
chance it is it is a cartoon
The gadget put it down.
I don't know!
Yabba-dabba-doo!
Yabba-dabba-doo?
What are you saying?
A hunting me will go.
Snuffy, it's Granddad.
What do you mean?
What the fuck does that mean?
mean it's granddad lock in my answer I'm saying it's
granddad elderly granddad Flintstones what does that mean my
chat is spamming granddad I don't know what you not know
what Flintstones are they're calling you old or something
wait what dad you don't know
the dinosaurs yes I hate I fucking hate the Flintstones like
I I actually hated that show Yeah, I saw blood in my eyes
when I wouldn't that would come on TV because why do you
don't like Bambam and Nobody in that show matters other than
the the only the like main guy character He's the only one
that actually matters in the show and ever does anything and
all he does is like bitch What the fuck I used to wish the
most like
body that's all he would do is he would just come back from
work and be like work at rock factory fucking sucked in my
stupid rock wife and rock kids are so annoying I'm just
going to watch my fucking rock dog yeah but fucking dude it
was like an Adam Sedley movie from the 2000s except it was a
cartoon me and my fucking chud you're not even what about
the the jetsons oh that one i don't think i even got to see
much i think that one was not on the tv a lot for me oh my
god maybe it was canadian oh my god game of throne boom i
heard like the newest show like the newest spin-out came out
recently wait there's another one yeah like the the dragon
yeah i heard it was another one yeah that was like that's
like ages old though no there's another new one came out
like a couple of weeks ago or like last week yeah that one
was i know because my manager fucking loves game of thrones
it's like oh my god the newest one just came out like our
manager wait you're just gonna say it's like uh oh yeah he's
never talked about game of thrones to me i'm gonna i'm gonna
next meeting on him i'm gonna be like hey bro you will you
watch you want to have no game of thrones huh yeah you have
told me about the new show just came out i'm gonna get like
work points yeah i'm gonna get a raise chat yeah yeah he's
like wow dude why you want to know more about my interest
let me find stuffy more sponsors now let me get dude hell
yeah donkeys oh yeah he's gonna give me like a game of
thrones like he's gonna give me a game of thrones sponsor
he's like you know i was saving this for Doki because you
have so much interest for Game of Thrones.
Why don't you why don't why don't you take this one?
I have never have you seen Game of Thrones?
No I've never watched.
I told this before to my chat but every time I would
accidentally catch an episode of Game of Thrones it was like
people fucking.
So then I was just like it was so awkward for me because I
caught my dad watching an episode and it was like two ladies
naked kissing each other and then I was just like oh were
you young were you like was that crazy yeah i was just like
yeah no i was oh it was very inappropriate for me to see
that that show was this old yeah for those who don't know it
when we were like our manager um i recommend stuffy didn't
have a manager before and then i recommended her okay okay
you're calling me homeless okay yeah sure yeah it's true
it's true yeah she would no they had to know they had yeah
but you're not homeless no more no more so then i got a job
now i was just like oh you want to use my manager like he's
looking for a new client so now we share a manager yeah yeah
yeah we share the same staff oh yeah stuffy is like the
first uh person that my manager got that's not me like the
the first hire on team donkey bird york yeah yeah because i
was just like because i was like she had to do everything
herself and i was like are you crazy like yes that's why
i've gone absolutely fucking insane yeah yeah no she had
because like i think like we both had the same like i
recommended snuffy for a sponsor together and then she was
like negotiating her own sponsor prices and stuff and it was
so low and then like my manager found out like how much
stuffy was getting paid for the same sponsor that we were
doing together and then i was just he was like does stuffy
need a manager because like i literally show up to like the
business chat and i'm like ten dollars yeah he's ten dollars
it's like um it's ten dollars too high i could go to nowhere
and then i was like stuffy do you do you want to use my
manager like do you dm me like That's not, that's, what are
you doing?
I'm listening to this is for really, you're really saying
this to people.
And I was like, six, seven.
She's like, what the fuck are you doing?
Like, why?
Yeah, well, I've talked to Chad a bit about it, too.
You know, I've praised a lot of the new stuff I've been
doing too.
It's great.
So it's been awesome.
It's great stuff.
I'm very, very thankful that I was, like, pitied upon.
That's funny.
chat this is why it's it's always good being honest be
yourself because somebody will just see how sad and pathetic
you are like a little animal on the street like we gotta
save her we gotta chop this little raccoon out in the rain
literally it's a found family yeah so stuffy shares my staff
team now um and they help they help her a lot as well so
that's why we are like our manager yeah we come from the
same family we share that we came from the same home okay
our home all right but you're I won't say it
you're the no you're like the you know what I mean it's sure
there's gonna be a beautiful word coming from you in just a
second to describe okay so you know like I'm the shining
star oh my god you're being chased by the saber-toothed I'm
loring away from our home I'm protecting this place you're
like you know like under the stair the hole under the
stairway like the Harry Potter shit yeah you're like I like
the those are named the Dursley or whatever the fuck that
just means you're calling yourself Dudley or whatever the
guy jumps on the stairs like wake up porno wake up we're
going to this day
we found her in the yeah we found her in the dumpster no
that's just where i go that place is kind of chill you ain't
got no place to go it's okay now you do but yeah now you do
that's why that's why oh wait what the fuck wait i shouldn't
fuck with this i got no
wait oh wait he wants me come keep running keep running keep
running don't worry i got you oh my god he wishes he wishes
he took that attack he wishes oh wait he's but he's bugged
oh my god he's no longer he was stunned what he said where
did you get out of this cloud behind him wait i shouldn't
get anything that's stupid
so we're a family now am i a freaking embarrassing story
that's so everybody used to think i was good at business now
they're gonna know i'm nothing but it was everybody um like
at least three people in my chat probably thought i was good
at what i do they're like whoa stuffy became a lot of
sponsors lately stuffy yeah i'm pulling in the you know
people just crowd around me and they're like whoa miss
snuffy you gotta sell our product you're legendary
yeah now we gotta fight for fight for it would be like no
give me the sponsor oh yeah now we could that we could play
favorites and be like what that's not fair it's not fair why
did she get the sponsor and i don't i wanted to play large
anime girl jumping breasted booby mobile game first person
shooter what the hell
fair should we just like have you really investigated these
caverns i don't think i did i was just i should put some
stuff away the grim reaper that's why we both got snow brick
yeah yeah pretty much we both got snow brick disappointed to
see i saw your reactions dude dude so fucking good oh yeah
no yeah i didn't realize how Nothing, nothing prepared me
for that, seriously.
Like, I looked up the game and I was like, this looks
interesting.
They're like, make sure to be able to activate the special
scene.
And I was just like, how the fuck?
And then that scene was very special.
I can't even tell which one you're talking about because
they're all really special.
Yeah, they're all really, really special.
So special, my YouTube got taken.
Oh, wait, have you talked about it?
that i thought about it a little bit on my stream oh yeah my
so you go you go yeah yeah um so now snuffy it played snow
brick first and then my my turn snuffy was like the guinea
pig before
i literally watched your youtube video and i was like
shaking my head like she learned she did better than the bad
day because she's so much dead body on the floor staff
because we share the same staff there's not just the manager
but we also have like the silent team is also um helping her
out so so um it's not just our our manager we have like two
what was a two or three other more staff members helping
stuff yeah and and stuffy was first for the snowbreak
because i had a little busier schedule so they're like oh
yeah we can yeah my schedule He's busy doing it.
So, so I, my, my sponsor stream was, that's why my sponsor
stream was like a week later.
And then, so, so they're like, they wanted a video upload
first for Snuffy.
Yeah.
And yeah, cause like, our sponsor editors are also the same.
So that's my, the editors that work for the sponsor videos
also edit for Snuffy as well.
You got the same editor too.
That's crazy.
oh my god i'm just shaking my head like so you guys they
learned
damn and then and then so everyone thought it was okay so
that's why like they uploaded the video they uploaded the
video on stuffy's channel because like the sponsor was like
don't worry be fine it'll be fine it looked fine i mean my
biggest gripe is that you can upload that to youtube and
youtube will just be like awesome yeah and then when you
finally click go live suddenly it's like actually i hate
that in your band what happened after you uploaded it yeah i
like had it uploaded for like 24 hours on my account and it
wasn't until i published it when it was suddenly like i'd
take it back this is this is filth and scum get out so then
and then she got She got, like, a fucking strike on her
channel.
And I was like, oh, no.
Dude, chat, those are bad.
Like, getting a strike sucks.
Yeah.
Super sucks.
Yeah, because you have three strikes.
But luckily, we found out that it goes away if you don't do
anything bad for three months.
So it resets your counter.
I'm on good behavior.
Yeah, if you're on parole, it's, like, on parole.
Yeah.
YouTube's got my balls in the grip.
from there like our staff team was like okay we can't upload
a video on ducky's chat we gotta we gotta make sure it's a
youtube short and also um censor everything more censor
everything that video is so censored it's so good oh my god
this thing just keeps going down yeah yeah yeah go down yeah
that's why i have the little hole here Don't worry you fall
from here.
You won't die.
That is a really you wish you had that hammer.
What happened to the hammer?
Oh, no, what did I ask?
Go pick up No, no, no, no.
What happened to that?
I gotta go.
Oh, you?
Okay,
okay, I got up here.
I got up here.
Yeah, this is what it's like to be the younger child.
You know what I mean?
Can you see it?
I'm the older favorite.
Oh my god, what is that?
What is that noise?
Oh my god, they're like flipping pages!
Put the books away!
It's a mage.
Alright, let's do this.
I'm like almost dead now.
There's like a ton of- Wait, I have to see here.
I'll give it here.
Here's a potion.
Thank you.
You probably got this from my dead body.
Probably.
But yeah, after that, um we were like i was just like i
heard what happened to stuffy i don't want that to happen to
me i heard what happened i'm sorry it's okay
oh my god i'm okay wait i'm almost got my old oh my god
there's like 20 dudes dokey turn around i know i'm gaming oh
i lost all my arrows wait i'm coming you gotta come down
yeah holy oh my god oh my god there's so many people here
dude we just freaking oh my god we like fucking killed
everything that's right that's our town it's our territory
we live here i got the the duo blades oh do blazer raid oh
my gosh pia pia thank you so much welcome welcome you guys
oh my god hey welcome readers oh my god we're playing
hightail have you guys played hightail i'm sure we have our
own server yes i have two servers accidentally oh oh pia
raided the youtube side thanks pia oh my god a good stream
oh we had a good stream hell yeah all right let's go down we
got we got it from both yeah thank you so much miss pf it's
so good to see you again oh my god this guy's in prison for
crimes what did he commit oh do i do like a backstab more
damage well that guy is like just chilling he literally just
let you kill him he tried he tried to fuck with me he wasn't
cool what did he do are there jump scares in this game wait
why you scared me to say that whoa oh my god it's like a
yeah little sight there's a bed here it's like a little
resting point oh my god i almost fell down
i sit so cutely yeah i wish i was a different angle though
ah sweet oh my god you are immune oh my oh stuffy stuffy
stuffy um if i if i maybe fell forward like two more feet i
think i would have lost everything that's okay that's okay
i've got some wild yeah yeah you're okay right yeah yeah
yeah we're still in this together don't worry i just got I
just got a little bit of a ground view.
There's actually a cave over here.
Maybe you want to come down and explore it.
Okay, let me make sure this...
Your half health, so...
Oh, you're right.
I was like, should I come down here?
This took me pretty low.
Yeah.
I do not fuck with that.
Can I eat the raw meat?
Do I die if I eat the raw meat?
What is that?
Oh, my God.
Oh, no, I'm fine.
Oh, yeah.
Oh, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom.
I did a hole in one.
I know, guys.
That was fucking cool.
Is that sick?
Hole in one.
I shouldn't laugh at my own, like, butt of the joke jokes,
but that was pretty good.
Yeah, I keep up with that joke.
Oh, whoa.
Oh.
There's a ladder?
guys i don't think there is a ladder
guys there's some like evil bugs down here i think this is
like the flying bugs but like these are the birthing queens
the birthing queens what the hive masters i'm gonna check
here real quick before i come down ant lion or some shit i'm
coming back i don't need to mine some rocks do this oh the
noises are just unpleasant all right i got some rocks
international sensation snuffy yes that's right i am the
international sensation snuffy welcome whoa you sound like
like a radio host there no thanks i love doing voices other
voice can you do i know you could do i remember like the
lowest voice i haven't done the lowest voice in like a long
time i think i can't do it anymore I was doing it on top.
What other voice can you do then?
I don't know.
They just... I think I have like a problem with my brain and
they just come out of me.
I don't actually... I'm not even aware.
It just happens.
It just comes to you naturally.
Yeah.
It's the...
Okay, so I don't really know where you are.
I'm in the endless caverns.
AMA.
I'm slowly digging down.
Oh.
Okay, so that works.
Hyrule chest and it gave me grain.
Okay, Hyrule what?
I mean, you need food, right?
I don't even think I can eat that.
It's like paper scraps.
Wait, where did you go, Jeffy?
Um, in the hole.
Yeah, but we're in the hole.
I took some legs.
Did you keep going down?
Yeah, yeah, we it'll come back.
back.
Oh wait, no you did.
You're like here.
Oh, there's... I don't have a little farting ants are back.
Wait, there's scorpions here.
What the fuck?
Wait, there's like...
Did you go to this... Wait, did you check this place out?
No, I don't think so.
This place looks cooler.
Oh yeah, I did.
I did go down there for just that area, though.
I didn't go any further here.
Yeah.
my god oh my god there's a scorpion yeah that's not a scene
there's a scorpion i was fighting like ant lines ew it's
like so squelchy wait where are you right behind you you can
probably hear me fighting for my life behind you whoa whoa
wait what the fuck is this area there's like goblins and
stuff here oh boy i got my God ass ham.
Actually, I'm going to use this.
Oh, nice.
He's dead.
Is there actually more mock damage?
I'll save you.
I'm like an exclamation point over his head.
Oh, I can't shield.
I wonder if there's, like, backstab damage, too.
In my mind, there definitely is, and I'm backstabbing for
the one's damage.
Oh, that's a lot.
Watch your step, watch your step, watch your step.
Watch your step.
yeah we are we are in the bowels of it these guys have oh my
god okay I need to eat oh oh there's frogs uh chefy I do not
feel safe no more oh oh um I may or may not be um um running
out of food maybe we just gotta kill more things to get more
food um I have zero food right now and i do not i this looks
like oh they it does look like the nether i got it
but how do you have you have stuff for meat yeah some a rat
dropped that you can have it oh thank you yeah i can give
you some arrows oh thank you yeah i got you wait i have your
mace did you Yeah, it's uncommon.
Did he's hurt?
Yeah, those are like frogs.
They're gonna pull you in.
Oh!
No!
Why did it pull back?
Well, oh no!
We're gonna get stolen by the frogs!
Um...
No!
Oh!
Fuck.
I lost everything but 100,000 pieces of sand.
You gotta go back.
No, not...
No!
At least you got the sand, though.
You know, at least you get to keep the sand.
I think we got flipping plenty of sand.
We're literally in the sand pits.
Oh, fuck out.
Okay, well, you know what?
It's just good to get the damage out early.
Where did we die?
100, 100, 100.
brian we need more chests that's for sure it has to be a way
to upgrade chests there has to be it's like i feel like
these chests are top too tiny i think it's like you have to
upgrade the the benches and stuff oh that makes sense here
i'm just gonna put yeah how did i get back to where we were
oh we definitely don't need sad in here
Uh, fuck, y'all carry more garbage in my inventory.
Where are you?
Oh my god, I could have got food.
I went to go get our items back.
Are you actually getting going to get your stuff back?
I don't actually think we had anything valuable, to be fair,
which is pretty funny.
I'm gonna eat my apple.
Yum, yum.
I can't actually figure out how to get back there.
something for us.
Come back here.
Okay, okay, okay.
Duffy.
I'm coming.
I have something special for us.
Okay, I'm back.
Oh.
Are you ready?
What the fuck?
What?
What's Axel F?
What's Oh, you cannot dog on me for the Flintstones and not
no Axel F.
It's fucking crazy frog.
Okay, but I call it as crazy frog.
I don't call it as...
He has numerous...
No, no, it's all crazy frog.
No, well, yeah, but like he all...
He has multiple songs.
They can all be crazy frog.
When the world needed him, the most he disappeared.
He started selling NFT.
No, not mine.
crazy fry i'm afraid he got a little too crazy he got a no
he got too crazy he got fucking loco axel f is from an old
movie okay name the movie if you know old movies three old
movies name three of the movies again yeah name three old
movies it is it's with Eddie Murphy?
Wait, what?
Beverly Hills Cop?
Beverly Hills, these cops?
I think I saw that movie, like, Blockbuster.
Beverly Hills Cop.
Blockbuster?
And Beverly Hills Cop 3.
Have you ever watched Mock Cop?
Dude, I typed in Beverly Hills Cop, and I get a song from
Pantian Stocking, and it's just called Beverly Hills Cock.
Epic reference.
guys i didn't know that did you know that was a reference to
this movie called beverly hills cop my panty and stocking
wait it wasn't you know you can upload oh it's a space you
can upload your own songs to this you know that for this mod
is it like it's like starbound oh use media spirit yeah you
just i have so many midi files wait do it upload something
wait upload something right now is it like live upload you
just yeah yeah yeah hold on let me see okay how many file
you have um i don't know i
have to find i have to find where i put them all
show us your meaty playlist
I have no idea where I put it.
Oh, no.
We'll never know.
I know.
What's Halloween?
What is Halloween?
It's a holiday.
Silly.
Really?
What month is it on?
Halloween.
It's on Halloween month?
Halloween month.
Chat, where's the...
Wait.
Why is that Michael Meyer?
Wait, that's Michael Meyer's theme.
Wait, it's literally Halloween from the Halloween movie.
I'm going to hit you with one of these sand blocks.
Wait, you have what?
Wait, where do I put this?
Where do I put the songs?
You put like, you could do upload, and then it should lead
you to a file, doesn't it?
Yeah, pull up your melody thing, and there's upload.
URL to MIDI file.
Chad, I can't show you my URL.
crazy it's gonna say like big fat ass file huge fat ass file
tiny dick folder like you can't see that what's the one they
know they'll never look in that's your safest your safest
files are in tiny dick folder yeah the ones where like you
know people are gonna open and there's like a joke folder no
because that they'll want to open big dick file oh so they
won't so they'll never tiny dick folder that's true that's
true they'll never open tiny dick folder that's where my
taxes go it's above average oh my god it's actually above
average yeah not when you compare it to me
whoa dude i don't know where i got this yeah rusty iron axe
but it goes crazy
Farmer's work, Bench.
Wait, we can finally farm.
We are finally farmers.
Yeah.
I shall play you a song while you work.
Wow, Snuffy.
I don't think she realized, matured.
She's been doing most of the work and I've just been playing
on my guitar.
That's not true.
I think you put in a lot of hard work.
an effort when you assassinate me at every corner you put a
lot into a lot of thought into my it's like no i'm trying to
make you adapt you know the more you die the more you're
adapting the more that it's the more you're muted you know
how i'm the only one who's who's lived most of the time
exactly yeah the like what doesn't kill you makes you
stronger this is this is how like boxers train you know they
spot yeah dude where is regular stone do we have a singular
i don't think so i there's no stone in the desert that's
like the only the only issue this place is almost perfect
except we don't have stone give me your magic spellbook nerd
yeah nerd get out of here this is our neighborhood you
definitely can get it as like a drop i bet this is our
neighborhood get out of here oh boy thousands of stone in my
inventory oh my god what did you do you just what you did
this you did this no no i did not do any what the oh at
least we got a sunroof now yeah wow this place is really
open
holy i have so much sand it's all sad what do we do i hate
sand this portion gets in everywhere
Okay, I'll just go into the pit of despair for a singular
rock I want to get mine if you mine the cobblestone does it
give us rock or do they not count as rocks?
I think it gives you oh, yeah, there is cobblestone in here.
Yeah, that's what I'm saying does do they count as rocks?
Yeah, yeah, yeah, it's fine
What what what I don't know what you're trying to do we were
going crazy.
I was like falling through the earth I Uh, what's out of
bacon?
Oh, it's a bit of my farming stuff.
Oh, we can have trees.
Oh, we are not planters.
Oh, we can have bees.
I'm trying to still see where my freaking midi files are.
Oh my god, I found them all.
Joe.
I found them all.
We should have got them all.
Chat, what are we?
What are we?
What do we hit them with?
Oh my god.
what are you gonna hit us with my god i literally have a
thousand songs all right guys get ready we're gonna have our
own little mini concert what do we do upload melody name you
are out like like the location i think so yeah if i put the
whole folder will it just put them all in it no probably not
i don't know oh my god wait i'm gonna try this one if you're
smart and cool you'll know what
can't paste it hello copy as a path there we go you have to
actually fucking put it what wait you have to use a real url
wait what wait look up a meaty file then and test it out
what what meaty.com give me the file delete that s oh delete
the quotes oh you're right you're right delete the quotes
from the copy paste these are all from final fantasy don't
laugh at me i mean not the songs
all right i'm waiting oh okay it says i can't use local
files unless i'm connected locally so it doesn't it doesn't
let you upload them
fuck god dang it i wanted to play my epic song i was gonna
play pokemon mystery dungeon you ever play pokemon mystery
dungeon oh i love pokemon mystery dungeon yeah it was like
one of my favorite games oh you're bluffing no i played it i
got like i played all of mystery dungeons except for like
the remaster because i heard that one was it was kind of
weird i didn't it's like it's like the 3d stuff yeah i like
liked it and then i just didn't like it as i yeah and then i
think the only thing i liked about the 3d uh i never played
it but i saw like videos of it was the the sarcophagus
pokemon and he was just like yeah yeah and he was just like
fucking running at you with his hands oh yeah animation for
that she was crazy I feel like I played that one but I don't
remember I'm gonna have to look that up I'm trying to farm
people like there was never a remaster there was a remaster
it was for the switch yeah people are in denial they're
coping yeah it was like it was cool but they changed like so
much of it so it was sort of like a reboot i heard like a
lot of remasters they make it easier to make the game easier
and stuff i kind of liked how punishing that game yeah like
you know like the monster house oh my god that would just
end around instantly yeah and then you would get another one
right after the first one yeah and then my my solution when
a monster i just i i kill off one of my teammates but i can
go back in the tunnel that's that's You wouldn't just get,
like, teleported away.
You'd step on, like, the warp pad and then just be like, oh,
that's true.
And you teleported away.
Oh, yeah.
And then you're, like, there's no, there's no, like, um, uh,
like, tunnel that you can just, like, hole yourself in.
Wait, where the fuck did you go?
I'm right outside.
I went back really quick to get the seeds because I'm going
to start.
Wait, I got to make a watering can.
Oh, oh, you're going to farm?
Wait, I have seeds, too.
Yeah, yeah.
I took some from the chest.
Oh yeah, I have a...
I have a turnip seed bag.
I think we need to start actually farming.
That's what I'm doing.
What do you mean, silly?
I realize that we lack food.
A lot of food.
Don't worry, I know how to survive in this wilderness.
Wait, where are you?
I'm crafting a watering can.
Downstairs?
Oh, I see you.
our farm outside or i put it like um a little bit outside
where the grass was like where we killed that lion oh the
saber tube yeah all right i know from here that's where the
sun pokes out there we go we go here to go to the oh there
it is oh wait no that's just emerald empty watering can okay
i got a watering can and i got seeds in a hole and dokey
okay i'm gonna choose to ignore that um i let the squatter
live in my house and now maybe i want i feel like an
evicting type type of mood now
food wait where's the water is there water somewhere okay i
think we need to start patching the holes maybe maybe our
house sucks i think maybe no it doesn't suck is that we just
have too many holes in our house just maybe we have too many
holes that we created it's all sand there's no way Where the
fuck did I fall?
I fell into some random ass hole.
Oh my god, there it is.
Oh my god.
Are you fucking kidding me?
This is the hole I fell in.
This is...
Oh my god.
I am never...
I still have not yet to find our little...
Our little gardening...
Patch.
Did you...
Did you craft the watering can?
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I just...
I'm watering.
wait where are i where are you i found you wait i i i don't
find you there's too many dead bodies i can i unmark my dead
but okay there you remove my see me i saw you are you using
some sort of like sad low what they call i see what you went
all the way oh wait that's where you're getting it's right
outside the house bro it's so far from my i place there's
real grass yeah we could move the dirt to our house our
house sucks you take that back i worked so hard in the house
you take that back i don't know if they'll just grow no no
no oh oh i thought you were messing and i pulled on no no
you didn't yeah i put turnip there you go That's all my
seeds.
Wait, I've wheat!
I've wheat!
Okay, apparently...
Wait, wait.
Oh, I'm eating my wheat.
Never mind.
JK, I thought I could plant this.
I think you could just probably plant it in the grass?
Probably not even plant this.
That's harvested weed.
You hooligan?
Wait, what the fuck?
It started growing.
Wait, if you just spam it, does it just grow?
I don't... Do you think that's just over time, or are you,
like, gaslighting me into thinking that I can never stop
watering?
Look, you spammed it, and it just started growing really
fast.
You're doing it.
No, I was just gaslighting you.
I wanted to see if you'd do it.
I'm squirting my can as hard as I can.
I don't like the way it just squirts out like that.
I can't just do, like, a long stream.
Wait, it did work!
Wait, what?
wait it works no wait then water this one are you sure it's
not just tab no because it did those out of order see i told
you it worked you didn't believe me oh this is not pouring
i'm like look look look oh my god i did that wait keep keep
keep doing on this one and then see if it keeps growing
bigger wait no you're not i don't think you're it, right?
I don't know how to water it.
I'm just kind of, like, spraying it.
Oh, it's time and water.
So water does help.
Yeah.
That's a weird-ass watering animation.
It's really uncomfortable.
I'm, like, shaking one out.
Chad, is there magic in this game?
Can I tell you spells?
Come on.
What?
There's magic, apparently.
Like, we gotta level up more, though.
We gotta have more memories.
I don't even know where it's the closest portal for us.
Oh, there is.
On the map.
I mean, we go to the...
Before we go, let's go cherish some memories.
It's like, follow me.
Oh, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Yeah, yeah, let's deposit some memories real quick.
We picked our nose sufficiently now.
It's time to say goodbye to these memories.
Goodbye.
That's crazy.
Can you link me that study?
Are you, are you like fucking paranoid now?
You're like, oh shit.
I was always wondering why I don't have good memory.
It's gotta be because I don't pick my memory.
There's like some inflammation shit or something.
Always this way.
That's like crazy to me because it must actually mean that
like people are like digging in their brain hole.
What the fuck?
Oh my god.
Oh that's what was shooting me.
Oh, there's some hyenas here.
Oh my god, you're getting chased by a pack of hyenas.
That's okay.
I'm built different.
Shoo-mah-on.
There you go.
Oh, and apparently, next patch, they're adding necromancy.
That's cool.
What?
That's fucking sick.
I want to do that shit.
Bro, I'll wait for the next patch.
I mean, we have the server for a month.
Hell yeah.
I want to try the magic.
That sounds cool.
All right, we have...
Oh, I think that's this.
We have alchemist's workbench now.
Oh, I didn't realize this actually had purpose.
Be real.
Yeah, we have the alchemist workbench.
That's fun.
I had lots of fun.
I didn't know.
Unlocked.
Oh, you go there.
Look at the chest.
It shows you.
Decorative chests.
Morph potion.
Eternal seed.
Oh, the next one.
patches this weekend.
That's fast.
That's really fast if it's the next patch.
You can make teleporters too.
Oh yeah, I saw that.
Okay.
Cool.
That's fun though.
It definitely feels more like Terraria than Minecraft in my
opinion.
I don't think I can ever think of Terraria in a 3D scenario.
To me, this is definitely Minecraft.
This is definitely just Minecraft.
Terraria, if it was 3d only because of how detailed some of
the stuff is especially with like the different types of
weapons you can use like the that's true I do think like the
armor too the armor tiering reminds me of Terrarium it's
like palladium and shit yeah yeah but that was fun exploring
I feel like we didn't explore that much too but we already
like encountered a lot of shit I didn't know what to expect
I didn't know how much content this game had already but the
fact that it showed me another never patched this weekend
too for even like the fact that the patches are coming out
really fast as well yeah that's really cool i'm not i'm not
used to games up dude like updating like i was gonna say up
duty yeah because everyone's for the gold yeah is that is
that i think it's crazy stuck in a hole for 30 minutes yeah
we didn't miss out on some cool things i would never i guess
i'll never see the dwarf lair the dwarf castle oh yeah you
never got to see the yeah the molten sword zombie that was
pretty sick yeah you would have known those frogs were not
to be fucked with as well i didn't i i was like what are you
doing and he fucking sucked me in and i was like oh that
what you do he sucked us both yeah and like back when they
were like when the game first came out like when people
could access it, they're like, oh, it's early access, it's
very early access, guys, so please don't judge it too hard.
But it's surprisingly a lot.
Like this game right now?
Yeah.
They were like being like, guys, we're sorry that it's like
very early access or there might not be, there's not a lot
of content.
But I feel like there was a lot of content.
There was a lot of content locked behind that $60 price tag.
Yeah, there was.
Yeah.
Looking at you?
I mean, look at me.
Wow.
yeah you wish you were you wish you were draped up like me
right now the animal ears were paywall that flip they got me
with that i didn't know you wish you were draped up oh i
believe it's because i believed in them and you didn't you
didn't believe in them you didn't believe in hightail's
future but i know i definitely thought this was gonna be
like a roblox game i mean that in the best with thought it
would be more like not a ton of content i guess you know
like you play it for a few hours you're like okay i've seen
it all yeah but there's a lot of stuff that we haven't seen
oh my god i love their daddy 97 whoa and thanks for joining
me snuffy yes thank you thank you miss doogie yeah if you
ever want to play on the server yourself like the server is
up for a month so if you want to drop in okay yeah maybe
wait are you thinking of adding anybody else to it i don't
know i mean if you want to invite anybody you can honestly
like i i already paid for it gotta make you set up servers
i'm gonna invite everybody to this second one and then i'll
be like i don't know what's going on dude i i can't find you
anyway yeah take a screenshot and i'll be like no look i'm
in doki server right now where are you yeah yeah yeah and i
i have two servers for a month right now so if you want to
invite anyone on a server you can just like obviously what
the am i gonna do with two servers like two servers two
servers being plagued by stink bugs hold on yeah so you want
everyone to play on it like by yourself or off at just you
could hop on whatever you want uh gt stuffy gt take nothing
personally wait do i have any fuck i don't have any water
wait Hold on, wait, hold on, wait.
I'm waiting, I'm waiting.
Can you even take water in here?
I don't know if you can take water in Peace Land.
You're not allowed to touch everything.
Hold on, wait.
Yeah, but you're not allowed to touch anything here.
No, negatively.
You can take water.
It's free.
It's their water.
Do they know that?
What is this, Starbucks?
Do they know it's free?
Wait, you actually can.
No, you can.
You can.
They won't let you starve in heaven.
You just have to be respectful.
and give it back after.
Hold on, I'm coming.
I'm waiting.
Okay, open one.
Wait, I can't water you.
Oh my god.
Not in heaven, you freak.
Not in heaven.
We're all pure here.
Can't do that in heaven.
You can't do that in heaven.
You can't.
You can't gouge your eyes out.
You know what I can do?
I can finally do this back to you.
You know what?
I can see why you're addicted to this.
Look at the pain face you make every time.
Okay.
Well, you can't play... Thank you, Doki.
Music isn't allowed in heaven!
What?
You can't... This is no heaven.
I can only play the sounds of God.
Yeah, not my heaven.
At least...
At least in upper hell, I could jam out.
dang uh chichi stuffy i'm gonna call it here and finish my
finish my dinner yeah and george probably definitely cold
man it's okay it was it was it was greek it was gyro so i
think i can eat it cold yeah i got myself nice gyro yeah i
stuffy are you still gonna be streaming i'll probably end it
too here honestly do you want to do like a duo raid on
somebody or if you're doing read i'm on youtube i mean yeah
but pia got us both dude that's true maybe someone else is
dual streaming is anyone multi-streaming especially this
late so don't know anymore yeah i don't know okay well no
pressure that's cool either way thank you for hanging out
yeah thank you snuffy for joining me i'm glad we got to
explore our headset together for the first time that's fun
oh somebody said clear does cleo oh they have a last name
i'm pretty sure cleo last name cleo first name cleo cleo
v2er cleo last name last name first name oh cleo eight oh
yeah yeah yeah yeah are they are they dual streaming i think
so that's what chat said i haven't rated i usually just read
myself oh you don't have no pressure i know i'm just trying
to remember how to do this when it's not myself i just raid
my waiting room that's cool you tuck them into bed and
you're like okay see you tomorrow oh i don't think i can oh
wait can i the waiting oh i can all right all right you rate
the twitch i rate the youtube okay all right guys i'm gonna
be late i'm gonna be late it's okay no my i my rate goes off
when i end stream oh yeah yeah all right guys as always
everybody say hi join the posture check up i'm around to get
that blood flowing and if you sell for me head to bed cause
you deserve it we'll see you next time everybody bye you
should get that blood flowing what does that mean yeah it
means remove your legs so the blood will come back to your
legs because you know when you're you know the reason why
they lost their like when you're sitting when you're sitting
down it's because when you're sitting down your blood isn't
flowing properly and that's why your your legs are sleeping
you know when your legs are sleeping that means your blood
flow your blood isn't flowing through your legs that just
means it's all flowing to your head so that's why they're
absorbing information yeah and start moving your moving your
body so the blood flows back okay everybody go up and run 10
miles get out of saying those are fun facts yeah and stop
your nose yeah and and don't oh yeah wait wait before we go
let me show you the picking nose causes um ashley was
looking that i was reading that up today this morning
because i was like i should not talk about that nobody
nobody talks about the dangers of picking your nose not
since you've been in kindergarten okay my rage is about to
go too wait wait wait here you go it's from the wait wait
wait before uh please be actually fake this guy's begging us
please please be fake you guys oh my god chat if I don't
catch you I love you goodbye goodbye thanks for being out
chat My curators, good night!
Here's a... I mean, it's what's the first journal I found by
googling it.
The first journal?
There's like several.
There's no thinking associated with Alzheimer's disease.
No!
Okay, I'm gonna end my stream now.
Please, please be fake news.
Please be fake!
Please, please.
It's skewed, it's skewed logic.
Anyway guys, bye bye everyone.
Goodbye Joker stream.
Goodbye Dragoons